EVERYONE WELCOME TO THE WATER
PARKS AND WILDLIFE COMMITTEE.
AND WE'RE GONNA GET STARTED
WITH OUR INFORMATION HEARING ON
SUBJECT BEING WHAT HAPPENS TO
WATER SUPPLIES DURING POWER
SHUT OFFS. LIKE TO CONVENE THIS
INFORMATION HEARING ON THE
IMPACT OF WATER SHUT OFFS ON
WATER SUPPLIES THANK YOU TO THE
OTHER COMMITTEE MEMBERS AND
GUESTS FOR ATTENDING. THANK YOU
TO EVERYONE WATCHING- THE LIVE
STREAM AND TO EVERYONE IN THE
ROOM AT TODAY. POWER OUTAGES
HAVE MANY CONSEQUENCES WERE
WONDERFUL POPULATIONS IN
CALIFORNIA'S. AN AT LARGE AS
MOST OF US KNOW CALIFORNIA
POWER UTILITIES HAVE
IMPLEMENTED PREVENTATIVE
POWERSHOT IVES IN ORDER TO
AVOID THE RISK OF THEIR
EQUIPMENT STARTING DESTRUCTIVE
WILDFIRES IN ADDITION
CALIFORNIA IS AT RISK FOR
UNPLANNED POWER OUTAGES DUE TO
STORMS EARTHQUAKES AND OTHER
EVENTS TODAY WE ARE HERE TO
LOOK AT POWER OUTAGES FROM THE
PERSPECTIVE OF WATER
COMMUNITIES. HOW DO YOU WATER
AGENCIES INSURE CONTINUED WATER
DELIVERIES WHEN THE POWER IS
OUT ONE OF THE CHALLENGES THAT
THESE AGENCIES ARE ENCOUNTERING
AS A RESULT OF POWER OUTAGES
TODAY WE WILL HEAR FROM THREE
PANELS OF SPEAKERS I ASK THAT
THE MEMBERS HERE THE
PRESENTATIONS FROM ALL SPEAKERS
ON THE PANEL BEFORE ASKING ANY
QUESTIONS. THIS WILL HELP US
STATE ON TIME. HELP OUR
DISCUSSIONS TODAY ARE
PRODUCTIVE AND RESULT IN A
POSITIVE NEXT STEPS THE STATE
AND ALL INTERESTED PARTIES CAN
TAKE TO ENSURE OUR
CONSTITUENTS. CONTINUE TO HAVE
DRINKING WATER AND WASTEWATER
SERVICES EVEN IF THE POWER IS
OUT. AT WITH THAT DO ANY OTHER
MEMBERS HAVE ANY OPENING
COMMENTS WORK. DR ALRIGHT WE'LL
START WITH OUR FIRST PANEL
PLEASE REMEMBER TO STATE. STATE
YOUR NAME AND THE ORGANIZATION
AT THE END OF YOUR
PRESENTATIONS PLEASE WELCOME.
FORT AS A FIRST STEP ANALYSTS
WILL BE ERIC THE MARU ACTING
DEPUTY DIRECTOR OF RESPONSE
OPERATIONS OF THE CALIFORNIA'S.
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE OF EMERGENCY
SERVICES AND THE OTHER IS THAT
DON BOLAN EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF
CALIFORNIA TO THESE EMERGENCY
ASSOCIATION WELCOME. AND YOU
MAY BEGIN. THANK YOU CHAIR AND
MEMBERS IT'S A PLEASURE TO BE
HERE TODAY AND THANK YOU FOR
THE INVITATION- TO SHARE WITH
YOU- OUR ROLE AND THE STATE'S
RESPONSE TO P. S. P. S. AND
THAT IMPACTS- THAT WE HELP TO
SUPPORT. WHY THE DECISION TO
IMPLEMENT P. S. P. S. RESTS
SOLELY WITH THE UTILITIES THAT
DECISION ALONG WITH THE- RED
FLAG FIRE WEATHER CONDITIONS
THAT EXISTED ACROSS CALIFORNIA
LAST YEAR. RESULTED IN THE
STATE HAVING TO MANAGE THE MANY
CASCADING IN COMPLEX. COMPLEX
CONSEQUENCES THAT ENSUED. WE
LEVERAGE OUR WELL ESTABLISHED
PREPAREDNESS AND RESPONSE
SYSTEMS. OUR PRIMARY EFFORT WAS
TO SUPPORT LOCAL GOVERNMENT TO
PROTECT RESIDENTS AND MITIGATE
THE IMPACTS LIFE PROPERTY IN
THE ENVIRONMENT. THE UNIQUE
CHALLENGES WITH THE OCTOBER PS
PS OF ANTS PARTICULARLY IN THE
CASES WERE OUTAGES OVERLAPPED
AN EXTENDED FOR MULTIPLE DAYS.
INCLUDED THE FREQUENCY SCOPE
AND SCALE AND ALTERNATE
CASCADING INTERDEPENDENT
LIFELINE IMPACTS AREAS THE
ENERGY. LEAVE SOBRE PS P.
JEANNIE INITIATED THREE SMALL
MORE DEFINED PS PS EVENTS IN
SCOPE AND SCALE IN JUNE AND
SEPTEMBER AND EARLY OCTOBER.
THE LONGEST LASTED ROUGHLY TWO
AND A HALF DAYS AND IMPACTED
BETWEEN FIVE TO TWELVE COUNTIES
RESTORATION FOLLOWING THOSE
SMALLER EVENTS WAS DONE
RELATIVELY QUICKLY. BETWEEN
OCTOBER NINETEEN ELEVEN P.
JEANNIE MADE THE DECISION TO DE
ENERGIZED A MUCH BROADER AREA
IMPACTING THIRTY EIGHT COUNTIES
AND IT WE ESTIMATE A POPULATION
OF ONE POINT EIGHT MILLION
PEOPLE. IN LATE OCTOBER P.
JEANNIE INITIATED THREE BACK TO
BACK EVENTS. ON THE TWENTY
THIRD TWENTY SIX AND TWENTY
NINE PERSPECTIVE LEE. AND AGAIN
THEY IMPACTED THIRTY EIGHT
COUNTIES MANY OF WHICH HAD BEEN
DE ENERGIZED SEVERAL TIMES. AT
THIS POINT THE FREQUENCY OF
THESE EVENTS WAS EVOLVING INTO
REAL AND SIGNIFICANT CHALLENGES.
ON THE TWENTY THIRD OF OCTOBER
P. JEANNIE DE ENERGIZED AN
ESTIMATED FOUR HUNDRED AND
FORTY SEVEN THOUSAND PEOPLE AND
SEVENTEEN COUNTIES. LASTING
OVER TWO DAYS THIS WAS
IMMEDIATELY FOLLOWED ON OCTOBER
TWENTY SIX WITH THE D. ENERGIES
ATION OF THIRTY EIGHT COUNTIES
WHICH LASTED OVER FIVE DAYS.
AND WHILE P. JEANNIE WAS
WORKING TO RESTORE POWER FROM
THE TWENTY SIXTH OF AT. WHICH
THEY WERE SUCCESSFUL IN SOME
BUT NOT ALL AREAS ADDITIONAL PS
PS WAS INITIATED ON THE TWENTY
NINTH OF OCTOBER THAT
OVERLAPPED MANY OF THE SAME
COUNTIES THAT WERE ALREADY DE
ENERGIZED. FROM THE TWENTY
SIXTH OF THAT. THIS OUTAGE
LASTED THROUGH NOVEMBER FIRST.
THE OVERALL IMPACT WAS AN
ESTIMATED POPULATION OF TWO
POINT FOUR MILLION PEOPLE
APPROXIMATELY SEVEN HUNDRED AND
FIFTY THOUSAND PEOPLE. WHO WERE
DE ENERGIZE OCTOBER TWENTY
SIXTH DID NOT SEE THEIR POWER
RESTORED FOR MORE THAN SIX DAYS.
AND WHAT'S IMPORTANT IN ALL OF
THIS IS I'M HIGHLIGHTING THE
NUMBER OF PEOPLE IMPACTED-
OBVIOUSLY AS WE WORK WITH THE
UTILITIES- THEY FOCUS ON THE
CUSTOMER IMPACT THAT'S A SINGLE
METER POINT. YOU KNOW BUT OUR
ROLE AT THE OFFICE OF EMERGENCY
SERVICES TO DEAL WITH THE
CASCADE THE CASCADING
CONSEQUENCES TO THE PEOPLE
INVOLVED AND SO ALL OF OUR
FIGURES A REFERENCE AN
ESTIMATED POPULATION OF
INDIVIDUALS IMPACTED BY THESE
OUTAGES. AT THE SAME TIME P.
JEANNIE WAS EXECUTING PS PS IN
THE NORTH NORTHERN CALIFORNIA
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA EDISON
IMPLEMENTED A SERIES OF EVENTS
STARTING ON OCTOBER NINTH BAND
THROUGH THE TWENTY SIXTH. AND
IMPACTED SIX SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA COMPANIES AN
ESTIMATED POPULATION OF A
HUNDRED EIGHTY ONE THOUSAND
PEOPLE AND LASTED BETWEEN TWO
TO EIGHT DAYS. IN THE FAR SOUTH
SAN DIEGO GAS ELECTRIC BETWEEN
OCTOBER TENTH IN THE TWENTY
FOURTH ALSO IMPLEMENTED THREE
SEPARATE EVENTS IMPACTING AN
ESTIMATED POPULATION OF FIFTY
FOUR THOUSAND PEOPLE. EACH
VARYING IN DURATION BETWEEN
SEVERAL HOURS TO UP TO EIGHT
DAYS. IN THE FRAME IN MID TO
LATE OCTOBER ALL THREE
UTILITIES. WERE SIMULTANEOUSLY
IMPLEMENTING PS PS. BEYOND THE
DIRECT IMPACT INDIVIDUALS
PARTICULARLY AS THE OUTAGES
EXTENDED INTO MULTIPLE DAYS
IMPACTS THE HEALTH AND MEDICAL
PROVIDERS SCHOOLS FUEL AND
COMMODITY DISTRIBUTION CENTERS
TELECOMMUNICATIONS
TRANSPORTATION MANUFACTURING
CRIMINAL JUSTICE WATER DELIVERY
AND WASTE WATER MANAGEMENT
EMERGED. THROUGHOUT ALL OF THE
EVENTS WE COORDINATED. WITH
UTILITIES TO ENSURE THE
COMMUNITY RESOURCE CENTERS THAT
THEY STOOD UP. WERE SET UP WITH
THE APPROPRIATE SCALE FOR THE
POPULATION IMPACTED BY THE
EVENT AND REMAINED OPEN AS LONG
AS POSSIBLE EACH DAY WITH
COMMODITY SUCH AS WATER ICE
BLANKETS AS WELL AS INFORMATION
AND POWER FOR INDIVIDUALS TO
CHARGE DEVICES. HELLO YES
FACILITATED ENGAGEMENT WITH
LOCAL LAW ENFORCEMENT IS
REQUIRED TO PROVIDE ADDITIONAL
SECURITY AT THESE SITES. GIVEN
THE SCOPE AND SCALE OF THESE
EVENTS AND DRIVEN BY THE
EXPECTED RED FLAG CONDITIONS
AND MUCH OF THE STATE HELLO YES
ACTIVATED THE STATE OPERATIONS
CENTER FOR OVER HALF OF THE
MONTH OF OCTOBER TO ADDRESS THE
CONSEQUENCES. WE MOBILIZED OVER
TWO HUNDRED AND FIFTY STAFF.
CLOSE TO NINETY STATE AGENCIES
TO SUPPORT THE STATE OPERATIONS
CENTER AND PROVIDE DIRECT
SUPPORT. TO MANY OF THE COUNTY
YEARS SEES THAT WERE ACTIVATED
TO DEAL WITH THE CONDITIONS.
CAL FIRE ENHANCE STAFFING
STAFFING PATTERNS AND PRE
POSITIONED ASSETS THROUGHOUT
THE STATE. CALLAWAY YES
STRATEGICALLY PRE POSITIONED
MULTIPLE CALLOW YES AND LOCAL
GOVERNMENT STRIKE TEAMS AND
TASK FORCES IN THE AREA. WHERE
THERE'S A HIGH FIRE THREAT AS
WELL AS PS PS CONDITIONS. WE
DISPATCH LIAISON PERSONNEL FROM
CALLAWAY US CAL FIRE THE PUBLIC
UTILITY COMMISSION TO EACH OF
THE UTILITIES EMERGENCY
OPERATION CENTERS WE DEPLOYED
STATE INCIDENT PLANNING
SPECIALIST TO THE P. JEANNIE
AOC. TO PROVIDE EXPERTISE ON
USING ICS SYSTEM AS WELL AS
TRIBAL AS WELL AS TRIBAL
LIAISONS TO WORK WITH P. GENIES
NEW TRIBAL LIAISON-
REPRESENTATIVE. THIS
COORDINATED EFFORT WAS
INSTRUMENTAL IN MAXIMIZING THE
PREPAREDNESS LEVELS RESPONDING
QUICKLY TO EMERGING SITUATIONS
AND ENSURING GOOD SITUATIONAL
AWARENESS. WITH RAPID RESPONSE
TO FIRES IN THE PROTECTION OF
LIFE AND PROPERTY. IN
PREPARATION FOR THESE EVENTS.
WE HAVE BEEN MEETING JOINTLY
WITH REPRESENTATIVES OF ALL THE
UTILITIES ALONG WITH THE UC AND
CAL FIRE LEADERSHIP FOR THE
BETTER PART OF A YEAR. DURING
TWENTY NINETEEN OUR GOAL WAS
AND ONTINUES TO BE TO ENSURE
THE UTILITIES RECOGNIZE AND
ADDRESS THE CONCERNS RAISED BY
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS AND SPECIAL
DISTRICTS. AS WELL AS OUR OWN
CONCERNS AND EXPECTATIONS AND
PROVIDING STATE AND LOCAL
GOVERNMENT. PUBLIC SAFETY
OFFICIALS WITH AMPLE
NOTIFICATION OF PENDING PS PS
EVENTS. FURTHER WE WANTED TO
ENSURE THAT THE UTILITIES
PROVIDE ACCURATE ONGOING
CRITICAL INFORMATION AND DATA
TO US AND TO THE PUBLIC.
THROUGHOUT THESE MEETINGS WE
WORK TO ENSURE THAT ALL THREE
UTILITIES WERE DEVELOPING
OPERATIONAL CONSTRUCTS. AND
PUBLIC FACING MESSAGING THAT
WOULD EXERCISE MORE CONSISTENT
ENTRANCE ACROSS THE BOARD
APPROACH WITH REGARD TO THEIR-
PUBLIC EDUCATION. THEIR
DECISION MAKING. THEIR
NOTIFICATIONS TO STATE AND
LOCAL GOVERNMENT AND THE ACTUAL
EXECUTION OF THE EVENT ITSELF.
IT'S STILL DURING THESE MULTI
THAT THERE CONTINUE TO BE CHAO
AN INK. WITH YOU. A ABILITY TO
PROVIDE DETAILED AND TIMELY
NOTIFICATIONS OF THEIR OUTAGES.
REQUIRED DATA AND DETAILED MAPS
OF ALGERIA'S DETAIL AND
CRITICAL MALE MEDICAL BASELINE
CUSTOMERS. SUPPORT TO CUSTOMERS
IN AREAS IMPACTED BY THE
OUTAGES AND INFORMATION AND TO
SUPPORT. OTHER CRITICAL
INFRASTRUCTURE NEEDS. DURING
THE EVENTS THE STATE
CONTINUALLY MODEL THE POSTURE
AND COMMUNICATION WE EXPECTED
OF THE UTILITIES WE TEAMED UP
WITH CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
COUNTIES IN LEAGUE OF CITIES.
TECH HELP KEEP LOCAL STATE
TRIBAL AND FEDERAL ELECTED
OFFICIALS IN THE IMPACTED AREAS
UPDATED. THROUGH THE CALLOW YES
FACILITATED CALLS THOSE
UTILITIES WERE THE PRIMARY
PRESENTERS OF INFORMATION AND
DURING THE NOVEMBER P. S. P. S.
EVENTS UTILITIES TOOK OVER THE
FACILITATION OF THOSE CALLS.
ANOTHER WAY IN WHICH THE STATE
STEPPED IN TO ENSURE THAT P.
GENIES WEBSITES AND CULTURES
WERE PREPARED TO SUPPORT
CUSTOMERS IS INCLUDED THE
DEPLOYMENT OF STATE PERSONNEL
RESOURCES TO P. JEANNIE. TO
STAND UP A NEW WEBSITE TO
PROVIDE INFORMATION TO THEIR
CUSTOMERS LASTLY TO ASSIST P.
JEANNIE AND ACCELERATE THE TIME
TO PROVIDE RESTORATION WE
DEPLOYED PLANES AND HELICOPTERS
WITH SPECIALIZED. FLEER
TECHNOLOGY FROM THE C. H. P.
AND THE NATIONAL GUARD TO HELP
P. JEANNIE INCREASE THE SPEED
OF INSPECTING THEIR LINES
FOLLOWING THE EVENTS.
PARTICULARLY AND I KNOW THE
INTEREST OF THIS COMMITTEE. IS
THE IMPACT WATER SYSTEMS WHICH
WAS CERTAINLY SIGNIFICANT. THE
AMP FOR WATER SYSTEMS THIS
MEANT THE CALORIE S.
COORDINATED WITH THE STATE
WATER RESOURCES CONTROL BOARD
DIVISION OF DRINKING WATER TO
IDENTIFY AND REACH OUT TO
DRINKING WATER AND WASTEWATER
FACILITIES AHEAD OF THE P. S.
P. AS EVENTS. TO IDENTIFY- WHAT
IMPACTS WERE LIKELY TO BE
EXPECTED. THIS CAUSED SOME
HEARTBURN IN SOME AREAS NO
ELECTRICITY- BY THE FOR THE PS
PS EVENTS MEANS WATER STOPS
MOVING STOPS BEING CLEANED AND
DURING THE P. S. P. S. EVENTS
P. JEANNIE REPORTED THAT ONE
THOUSAND SIX HUNDRED SIXTEEN
WATER AGENCIES WERE AFFECTED
ESTY JEANNIE REPORTED FIFTY
FOUR. IN PARTICULAR IN THE CITY
OF BENICIA THEY WERE RUNNING
WELL RUNNING ON BACKUP WATER
THE CITY LOST POWER THAT HAVE
NO WATER IN FAIRFIELD ONE WATER
TREATMENT FACILITY WAS OFF LINE
A SECOND FACILITY WAS
FUNCTIONING AND ABLE TO HANDLE
THE CAPACITY. IN GLEN THEIR
NATURAL GAS WATER PUMP STOPPED
WORKING IN ASSISTANCE WAS
DEPLOED TO FIX IT IN TAMING
COUNTY THE CITY OF RED BLUFF
HAD AN ISSUE WITH THE WATER
SUPPLY A LIMITED NUMBER OF
PUMPS WERE ON GENERATOR POWER
THIS WAS A CONCERN REGARDING
WATER TO A COUNTY JAIL
FACILITY. TO COMMUNITIES IN
TRINITY COUNTY STAGE WATER
TRUCKS SO RESIDENTS COULD FILL
UP BUCKETS TO USE FOR FLASHING
THEIR TOILETS AS A THIRD OF
WELLS. WE'RE IN A- DUE TO LOSS
OF POWER. COMMUNITIES OF COMPLY.
AND IN PARTICULAR IN THE TOWN
OF LAKE PORT- WE WORK WITH
PACIFIC GAS AND ELECTRIC AS
WELL AS OUR PARTNERS AT FEMA TO
GET BACK UP GENERATION TO
SUPPORT BOTH THEIR WATER
FACILITY AND THE WASTE WATER
TREATMENT FACILITY. WE ALSO
WORK WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF
WATER RESOURCES TO MAKE SURE
THE STATE WATER PROJECT WAS
OPERABLE THROUGHOUT THE SYSTEM.
ALL CRITICAL LOCATIONS HAD
EMERGENCY BACKUP GENERATORS
WITH THE EXCEPTION OF PUMPS AT
THE CORDELIA PUMPING PLANT.
THIS PLANT FEATS NAPA BENICIA
AND VALLEJO AND LARGE
GENERATORS EVENTUALLY ARRIVED
IN WERE HOOKED UP TO SUPPORT
THAT FACILITY. WE CAN ALL AGREE
THAT THE PS PS EVENTS LAST
OCTOBER PRESENTED US WITH A
SERIES OF COMPLEX CHALLENGES
THEY WERE SOMEWHAT MITIGATED TO
CALIFORNIA'S EXTENSIVE
CAPABILITIES AND EXPERIENCE
WITH MANAGING MAJOR
EMERGENCIES. AND DISASTERS
INCLUDING THE CAPABILITIES OF
OUR EXTENSIVE MUTUAL AID
SYSTEMS. HOWEVER HOWEVER AS
YOU'LL HEAR TODAY ABOUT THE
UNIQUE CHALLENGES FACED BY
WATER SYSTEMS THIS INFORMATION
CHAIR TODAY IN THREE PREVIOUS
REPORTS WILL HELP INFORM
PREPARATIONS FOR THE NEXT
ROUND. YES EVENTS. THANK YOU
CHAIRED MEMBERS FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK HAPPY TO
TAKE ANY QUESTIONS THANK YOU
ONCE GOT THERE WE GO JUMP RIGHT
INTO THE NEXT PRESENTER AND
THEN WE'LL OPEN IT UP FOR
QUESTIONS. THANK YOU CARE GOOD
MORNING I AM ON POLAND.
DIRECTOR LIAM MISSY ASSOCIATION
WE ARE THE M. ALL WITH YOU
PARTNER WITH OLD P. S. WILL
RESIDE IN THE STATE OPERATIONS
CENTER. WE WERE FORMED IN
NINETEEN FIFTY TWO AT THE
DIRECTION THE GOVERNOR EARL
WARREN. OUR ENTIRE FOCUS IN
THIS OP TIONS. PROVIDE MUTUAL
ASSISTANCE ALL HANFORD PLANNING
COORDINATION COMMUNICATIONS.
PLAN FOR ALL THREE AND POST
ANSWERS ENERGY EVEN INTEGRATED
PARTNERSHIP BETWEEN ALL OUR YOU
BILL AT LEAST. HE REPRESENTS
FORTY TWO POWER BENEATH
POLLUTING THE- PROGRESS TODAY.
HE REPRESENTS. REALLY WILL
IMPACT THE NEXT UTILITY. IN
DOING SO WE ASSEMBLED THE
UTILITY OPERATIONS CENTER IN
SUPPORT OF THE STATE OPERATIONS
CENTER IN THEIR CENTER HAS
ROUGHLY FOUR LEGS LIKE YOUR
DINING ROOM TABLE WE HAVE GAS
AND PIPELINE WE HAVE POWER
TELECOMMUNICATIONS AND WATER
WASTEWATER THE ADVANTAGE OF
HAVING THIS TOTALLY IN BETTER
IN- E. S. IS THE FACT THAT THE
P. S. P. S. PROVIDER. WHETHER
THAT BE LADWP SP G. ANY S. C.
E. OR P. JEANNIE WHICH IS THE
LARGEST CONTIGUOUS POWER
COMPANY IN UNITED STATES
ACTUALLY HANDS THERE IN THE
BILL AND THEY ARE AT A BASE IN
YEARS THE OTHER TO TELL THESE
BEING IMPACTED CAN EXCHANGE
REAL TIME INFORMATION AS TO
WHAT IS IMPACTED IN THE GRID
WHEN IT WAS IMPACTED IN THE
GRID. AND WHAT THE ANTICIPATED
EXPECTATION FOR THEIR IMPACT IS
UNDERSTANDING IN TWO THOUSAND
AND NINETEEN WE HAD MAJOR AND
SOME WHICH WE ARE ACTIVATED TO
SUPPORT DATA SINCE. IN A- FORTY
EIGHT DAYS COVER PS PS YOUR IN
THE RICH EARTHQUAKE IN TWO AND
EIGHTEEN WE HAD SEVEN EVENTS
WHICH RAN FOR NINETY FOUR
CALENDAR DAYS FOR PS PS SPIDERS
IN STORMS UNDERSTANDING THAT
WATER IS ONE OF THE UTILITIES
THAT CANNOT BE PHYSICALLY
PICKED UP AND MOVED LIKE WE CAN
GENERATION OR WE CAN MOBILE
COMMUNICATIONS IT'S IN BED IT.
AND AS SUCH WE HAVE TO ADDRESS
IT WHERE IT'S AT WATER IN AND
OF ITSELF CAN LAST ROUGHLY
THREE DAYS YOU CAN LIVE WITHOUT
THE INCONVENIENCE OF A CELL
PHONE FOR A WEEK IF YOU HAD TO
AND YOU PROBABLY LIVE WITHOUT
POWER IS INCONVENIENTLY AS YOU
CANNOT WITHOUT WATER NOR CAL
FIRE NOR CAL WE ASPIRE NOR CAN
THEY MEET SYMBOL. USED WHO ARE
CHARGED THE SUPPRESSION IN THE
EVENT OF A FIRE SO NOT ALL THE
WE HAVE TO IT UP THE ONLY WE
WOULD DONT FOR ST YOU WANT ANY
FOR YOUR SUPPORT CAPE SO THAT
WE CAN PER THE HOME EIGHT THE
UNITY. AND SAW THERE
COMMUNICATION WORKS ALSO WILL
HAVE A BETTER TO A CRITICAL
COMPONENT IN THE U. OP CENTER
SUPPORT THE STATE APPARATUS
CONSENT. THROUGH WORK ACTIVATED
IT HE RUBS THE SPOT OPERATIONS
IN REPORTS OF TO WHAT WE CALL
THE UC THE YOU CA GROUP WHICH
IS AGE CAL NATIONAL IN RDER TO
GET SITUATIONAL AWARENESS WE IN
BED THE CALIFORNIA ENERGY
COMMISSION IN THE YOU WILL SEE
BECAUSE FUEL BECOMES A CRITICAL
LIFELINE FACTOR TO KEEP THE
GENERATORS AND OR OTHER TYPE
PUMPS RUNNING WHEN WE DO NOT
HAVE POWER CAPABILITIES WE ALSO
IN BIT. ISEL CAL LYSOL OVERS
IT'S THE DISTRIBUTION OF
PROCUREMENT OF POWER FOR THE
ENTIRE GRID IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA SO THAT WE HAVE
ENOUGH POWER ALLOCATED TO AREAS
THAT IT ENDED UP RE ROUTED
STAND BY OUR AVAILABLE FOR
THOSE THAT ARE INVOLVED IN THE
P. S. P. S. OPERATIONS WE ALSO
HANDLE THE MUTUAL WE BROUGHT IN
OVER EIGHT HUNDRED GROUPS FROM
OUR- REGION AND OUT OF THE
STATE TO SUPPORT. IN A- SET.
THERE ARE LINES TO ONE TO THE
PSP A DOCTOR BY THIS. ALL LIE
MUST BE PHYSICALLY IN. IN ORDER
TO EXPEDITE THOSE INSPECTIONS
TO ALLOW THEM TO TURN THE GRID
BACK ON WE HAVE BROUGHT IN
MUTUALLY. AS IT COMES TO WATER-
WE HAD THE RIDGE CREST
EARTHQUAKE THAT CAME UP ON.
SEVEN FOUR EIGHT SIX FOUR AND
THEN AGAIN ON SEVEN FIVE IT IS
SEVEN ONE. WE PROVIDED MULTIPLE
MUTUAL ASSISTANCE COMPANIES ON
THE AFTERNOON OF SEVEN FOUR
FROM CAL WATER LED TO BE P. M.
D. W. D. W. R. TO SEAR WAS
VALLEY WATER COMPANY- WE WORKED
THROUGH CAL EPA CD PH IN THE
STATE OPERATIONS CENTER. MALL
HOBBY WATER DEPLOYED ALL OF
THEIR CREWS IN MUTUAL AID WE
HAD REST EIGHTEEN HUNDRED
INDIVIDUALS IN THEIR TOWN. ONE
OF THE BIG ISSUES IN THEIR OWN
IS THEY DO NOT HAVE SIGNIFICANT
AIR CONDITIONING. MOST OF THE
HOMES USED WHAT ARE CALLED
SWAMP COOLERS WHICH ONE ALL
THIS. WATER SYSTEM FOR THERE
EIGHT HUNDRED A MONTH BACK AND
SO HUNDRED NINE SIX CONNECTIONS
OUT FIFTY TWO OR COMMERCIAL
EIGHT FOR INDUSTRIAL AND WE HAD
KNOCKED OUT CHINA LAKE NAVAL
AIR STATION ALL RESTORED WITHIN
FOUR AND A HALF DAYS. BY
MULTIPLE OUTSIDE CREWS COMING
TO THE AID OF CERIALIS SO IN
ESSENCE WE IN FACT ARE THE CORE
COMPETENCY PARTNER OF OLD P. S.
FOR. I USE LIKE P. JEANNIE
MUNICIPALS LIKE LED B. P. AND
M. D. W. SEVEN TEEN CABLE AND
POWER. COMMUNICATION COMPANIES
FROM EIGHTEEN ANTI VERIZON
SPRINT T. MOBILE- WE HAVE ****
CABLE THE REST SO FROM THAT
STANDPOINT WE ARE A SUPPORT
PASSAGE THAT COVERS ALL OF THE
UTILITY BASES. REACHES OUT TO
HOME IN REAL TIME CAN LOOK AT
THE DATA IN REAL TIME THANK
ASSESSMENT TO. THE STATUS TO
THE STATE THAT NEEDS TO BE
BROUGHT THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME
THANK YOU TO BOTH OF YOU OPEN
IT UP TO QUESTIONS ABOUT QUIRK.
SO SEWERS CHOOSE ME. SANITARY
DISTRICTS- WHETHER TREATMENT.
OF FOR AFFLUENT ARM HOW MANY OF
THOSE WERE NOT ABLE TO FUNCTION
IN WHAT WAS THE ENVIRONMENTAL
AFFECT A WHICHEVER ONE OF YOU
CAN ANSWER. I WOULD HAVE TO
TAKE THAT AS A GO BACK FOR YOU
SIR- AND REACH BACK TO THE
STATE WATER RESOURCES CONTROL
BOARD- WHAT WE WERE LOOKING AT
WAS IMMEDIATE IMPACTS- SO THERE
ARE A NUMBER OF THOSE THAT WERE
RAISED TO THE STATE OPERATIONS
CENTER THAT WE ADDRESSED. BUT
OVERALL IMPACTS NUMBER OF
FACILITIES THAT HAD TO TURN TO
A BACKUP GENERATOR OR HAD
ISSUES WITH THE BACKUP
GENERATOR THAT WASN'T SOMETHING
THAT WAS NECESSARILY BEING
REPORTED UP TO US BUT WE CAN
PROBABLY WORK THE STATE WATER
RESOURCES CONTROL BOARD CAN
ACCOUNT OF THAT. ALL RIGHT AND
YOU MENTIONED IN TRINITY COUNTY
THEY WERE TRACKING WIDER
READING AND- HOW MANY- PEOPLE-
DID NOT HAVE WATER FOR SOME
PERIOD- DURING THE SHUT OFF.
POWER I THINK THAT'S GONNA BE
AN AREA THAT'S GOING TO BE
TOUGH TO QUANTIFY- BECAUSE
THERE'S A NUMBER OF INDIVIDUALS
WHO. WHO'S WELLS DID NOT WORK
BECAUSE OF THAT AND THAT.
THROUGH THEIR OWN MEANS I WORK
TO RESOLVE THAT PROBLEM AND IT
NEVER GOT ESCALATED AT THE
GOVERNMENT AS AN EMERGENCY
RESPONSE- BUT I WOULD IMAGINE
ACROSS THE SPECIALLY THE-
THIRTY EIGHT COUNTIES P.
JEANNIE IMPACTED MANY OF WHICH
ARE RURAL COMMUNITIES ARE A LOT
OF INDIVIDUALS- STRUGGLING WITH
THEIR- WELL SYSTEMS AND- AND
OKAY BESIDES WELLS. HOW HOW
MANY. YOU MENTIONED AGAIN
TRINITY COUNTY IS ONE PLACE
WHERE THEY HAD TO GIVE OUT
WATER- WHETHER OTHER PLACES
WHERE THEY HAD TO TRUCK IN
WATER. I WOULD SUSPECT THERE
THERE ARE- BUT THOSE DIDN'T
NECESSARILY REYES STAR LEVEL AT
THE STATE IF THEY WERE BEING
HANDLED LOCALLY BUT I SUSPECT
THAT THERE WAS OKAY. WELL
PERHAPS ONE OF THE OTHER-
PANELS CAN GIVE US MORE
QUANTITATIVE INFORMATION- BUT
IT'S VERY HARD TO KNOW- I JUST
HAVE SERIOUS THE PROBLEM WAS IF
WE DON'T HAVE THAT INFORMATION
AND THAT'S SOMETHING I THINK WE
REALLY NEED. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR THANK YOU ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS. COMIDAS THE ROLE OF
THE DIFFERENT AGENCIES AS IT
RELATES TO- THE STATE
OPERATIONS CENTER FOR EXAMPLE
DEPARTMENT OF WATER RESOURCES
IN THE C. U. P. HOW ENGAGED ARE
THEY- MAYBE YOU CAN KIND OF
GIVE US A BIT OF AN INSIGHT ON
THE LEVEL OF COMMUNICATION AN
INTERAGENCY COLLABORATION- SO
WHEN WE ACTIVATED THE STATE
OPERATIONS CENTER FOR THE PSP
AS EVENTS IN ADDITION TO WHAT-
MR BOLAND ARTICULATED THE
AGENCIES WE BROUGHT TOGETHER-
TO FOCUS STRICTLY ON IMPACTS
UTILITIES WE HAD CAL EPA AND
REPRESENTATIVES FROM THE STATE
WATER RESOURCES CONTROL BOARD
THE DEPARTMENT OF WATER
RESOURCES IN THE ROOM WITH US.
SO THAT THEY HAD DIRECT CONTACT
WITH THEIR CONSTITUENCIES- SO
THAT WE COULD UNDERSTAND WHAT
THE IMPACTS WERE SO THERE IS A
DIRECT DALY ENGAGEMENT- WITH
THAT STAFF TO HELP COORDINATE
AND I WILL TELL YOU THAT THE
STAFF FROM CALLIE PA WAS
INSTRUMENTAL IN GETTING US
VISIBILITY INTO WHAT SOME OF
THE IMPACTS WERE TO LARGER- A
MUNICIPAL WATER SYSTEMS AND
WASTEWATER SYSTEMS. AND SO THAT
WE COULD BEGIN THE PRE PLANNING
TO UNDERSTAND WHERE WE MIGHT
NEED TO DEPLOY GENERATION
CAPABILITIES SO REALLY WAS
INSTRUMENTAL THERE'S A- YES THE
WORK WITH THE- THE WATER
AGENCIES TO DEVELOP- EMERGENCY
SHUT OFF PLANTS IN THIS CASE.
SO YES DOES NOT. THE WATER
AGENCIES- THROUGH- THAT SUPPORT
OF THEIR COUNTY EMERGENCY
MANAGEMENT OFFICES WORK
INDEPENDENTLY TO BUILD THEIR
EMERGENCY RESPOSE PREPAREDNESS
AND RESPONSE PLANS- WE
CERTAINLY PROVIDE EXPERTISE-
WHEN REQUESTED IN THE
DEVELOPMENT OF THOSE PLANS
BRINGING AND- BEST PRACTICES
FROM OTHER JURISDICTIONS. WE
ALSO WORK- BEGINNING TO WORK
DIRECTLY WITH THE SPECIAL
DISTRICTS ASSOCIATION HERE IN
CALIFORNIA SO THAT WE CAN
PROVIDE MORE EDUCATION AND
OUTREACH TO A LOT OF THOSE. A
UTILITIES THAT FALL WITHIN THAT
THAT AREA SO BETWEEN BOTH OUR
ENGAGEMENT WITH COUNTY- YES
OFFICES THAT REACH DOWN- TO THE
PUBLIC AGENCIES WITHIN THEIR
JURISDICTION AS WELL AS- OTHER
OPPORTUNITIES WERE TRYING TO
EXPAND- OUR SUBJECT MATTER
EXPERTISE AND TRAINING TO
ORGANIZATIONS. WHAT THE
DIRECTIVE FOR- THE SHUT OFF TO
OCCUR. THE WATER AGENCIES
RECEIVED THAT IMMEDIATE
INFORMATION FROM- YES OR IS IT
DIRECTLY FROM THE TO LADY WHAT
IS THAT REPORTER CALL LOOK LIKE
SO THE UTILITIES PROVIDE A
SEVENTY TWO HOUR NOTIFICATION
AND THEN A FORTY EIGHT HOUR
NOTIFICATION WHEN THEY ARE
LOOKING AT DOING A PUBLIC
SAFETY POWER SHUT OFF THAT
COMMUNICATION FIRST GOES TO
CUSTOMERS SO IF THAT THE-
UTILITY AS A CUSTOMER OF THE I.
O. U. THEY'RE GETTING A DIRECT
NOTIFICATION FROM THE I OWE
YOU. A MANY LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
ARE ALSO DOING ADDITIONAL
NOTIFICATIONS OUT TO THEIR-
COMMUNITY- NGUYEN P. S. P. S.
EVENTS ARE PLANNED AND THEN AT
THE STATE LEVEL WE'RE SORT OF
THE THIRD LINE OF REDUNDANT IF
YOU WILL IN TERMS OF GETTING
NOTIFICATIONS OUT A TWO. ME
GINSENG. OFFICES TO ENSURE THAT
THEIR TRACKING THE EVENT. HAVE
ALL THE INFORMATION AND
PLANNING INTELLIGENCE THAT THEY
NEED. ALL RIGHT THE CLOSER. SO
DID YOU DID YOU ARE SUPPLY
BACKUP POWER TO EITHER SEWER OR
WATER AGENCIES. WE DID I'M
AWARE OF AT LEAST TWO
SITUATIONS AND LAKE PORT WHERE
WE PROVIDED GENERATION FOR
THEIR WATER AND WASTEWATER I
BELIEVE- CINNAMON QUIRK THERE
WAS ADDITIONAL- ADDITIONAL
CAPABILITIES REPORT WE PROVIDED
APPROXIMATELY FIFTY GENERATORS
ACROSS THE STATE WHEN I SAY
PROVIDED WE COORDINATED EITHER
TO THE DEPLOYMENT OF GENERATORS
WE HAD FROM FEMA WERE WE WORK
DIRECTLY WITH THE I OWE YOU- TO
REQUIRE THEM TO DEPLOY
GENERATION TO KEEP FACILITIES
SO- I'M AWARE OF AT LEAST TWO
SITUATIONS WHERE WE PROVIDE.
BACKUP GENERATION TO WATER AND
WASTEWATER FACILITIES AND
BELIEVE THERE MAY HAVE BEEN
MORE AS WELL OKAY THANK YOU.
OKAY ANY PUSH. YES. IF BONTA
AND WHEN AND NOT THE POWER WAS
SHUT OFF OF A LOT OF A- OUR
FOCUS RUBIO PS PS IS ACTIVATED
TO. YOU FORTY S. YOU OFFICE OF
EMERGENCY SERVICES THE WHOLE.
WOULD YOU. DO IT DIFFERENTLY
THAN LAST YEAR IN THE WEST WHAT
LESSONS HAVE YOU LEARNED FROM
IT. I THINK WHAT AREAS WERE
pSEVERAL MONTHS A IS
UNDERSTANDING. BETTER WHAT THE
CRITICAL VULNERABILITIES ARE AT
A LOCAL GOVERNMENT LEVEL- SO
THAT WE CAN PRI PLAN WHERE
ASSETS FROM THE STATE MAY BE
REQUIRED OR ASSETS FROM THE
OHIO USE MAY BE REQUIRED TO
SUPPORT. A LOCAL CRITICAL
INFRASTRUCTURE INCLUDING WATER
AND WASTEWATER FACILITIES SO
WE'RE GONNA BE WORKING WITH THE
COUNTIES. DEVELOP A PROCESS.
YOU COLLECTED UNDERSTAND
CRITICAL INFRASTRUCTURE WHAT
BACK UP CAPABILITIES EXIST AT
KEY FACILITIES SO WE'VE GOT A
BETTER UNDERSTANDING OF WHERE
THE WHERE THE GAPS MAY BE AS WE
GO INTO AN EVENT TO HELP US BE
MORE PREPARED TO RESPOND IF YOU
HAVE- DIFFICULTIES-
COORDINATING. WITH A LOCAL LAN
JURISDICTIONS LAST YEAR AND THE-
WE ARE WORKING ON TO IMPROVE IT
I THINK AS WE REACHED OUT
THROUGH THE STATE WATER
RESOURCES CONTROL BOARD- WE DID
NOT RECEIVE A FEEDBACK WE WERE
HOPING FROM THE UTILITIES-
ESPECIALLY WELL WATER
WASTEWATER FACILITIES TO
UNDERSTAND WHAT THEY'RE
VULNERABILITIES MAYBE- IN IN
SOME KEY. AND THIS WAS NOT
NECESSARILY WIDESPREAD THERE
WAS THINK THERE WAS A CONFIDENT.
ONE EXPERIENCE THAT THEY COULD
MAINTAIN OPERATIONS BUT
CERTAINLY WHAT WE EXPERIENCED
IN THE LATE OCTOBER THAT'S WAS
ON THE SCOPE AND SCALE THAT WAS
MUCH GREATER THAN- MANY OF
THOSE INSTITUTIONS THAT DEALT
WITH PREVIOUSLY AND SO WE WANT
TO BETTER UNDERSTAND WHAT THE
VULNERABILITIES ARE- SO THAT WE
CAN. UNDERSTAND WHERE
PRIORITIZE OUR RESOURCES AT THE
GREATEST EFFECT. THE THAN THE
COORDINATING. IS THE A LAST
CHANCE NOW THIS YEAR THAT THE
EMERGENCY SHUT OFF FOR WILL
TAKE PLACE. AND THE- IF FOR A-
THAT IS SO UNFORTUNATE
SITUATION TO A- HAVE A ANNA
THOUGH I SHUT OFF- ACTIVATED
THEN. HI THIS SERVICE IN THE
VICTIMS OF MILLIONS OF PEOPLE.
IS THERE ANY OTHER THE
IMPROVEMENTS SAID THAT YOU'D BE
MAKING. SO OUR JOB IS TO DEAL
WITH THE CONSEQUENCE MANAGEMENT
WHEN THE UTILITIES MAKE THE
DISK INTO AN ISSUE A P. I. S.
THE UTILITIES ARE ARE INDICATED
TO US THAT THE STATE THAT THEY
ARE HOPING TO DRAW DOWN THE
SCOPE AND SCALE OF THESE EVENTS
THIS YEAR- WE ARE CONTINUING TO
PUSH THEM ON THAT FRONT- WHAT
WE ARE FOCUSED ON RIGHT NOW IS
A BETTER UNDERSTANDING WITH THE
GREATEST VULNERABILITY. THESE
ARE OUR THROUGHOUT THE BE
DINNER. AND THEN CONTINUING AND
OUR SYSTEMS THAT WE CAN BE.
FAST TO NEED AS THESE EVENTS
DEVELOP SO WE'RE NOT IN A
POSITION TO STOP THESE P. S. P.
S. EVENTS FROM OCCURRING- BUT
WE ARE IN A POSITION TO WORK
WITH THE UTILITIES. TO GET THEM
TO FOCUS ON REDUCING THE SCOPE
AND SCALE OF THESE EVENTS OF
THAT. CAN MITIGATE THE IMPACT
TO THE POPULATION TO THE BEST
WE CAN. THANK HERE QUESTIONS
OAK RIGHT WELL THANK YOU FOR.
IS ANY THIS MORNING WE
APPRECIATE YOU BEING HERE WHEN
ASKED AT THE OTHER TWO HAVE
PRESENTERS PLEASE COME FORWARD.
AT THIS TIME- JOE MCDERMOTT
DIRECTOR OF ENGINEERING
EXTERNAL AFFAIRS. AS WE CAN IS
MUNICIPAL WATER DISTRICT. AT
CLIFFORD CHEN DIRECTOR OF
OPERATIONS AND MAINTENANCE EAST
BAY MUNICIPAL. WATER DISTRICT
WHAT. WE'VE GOT A THIRD
DISTRICT AND MICHAEL A MENTOR
NAM JR MANAGER OF CALAVERAS
COUNTY WATER DISTRICT. GOOD
MORNING THANK YOU CHAIRMAN
GARCIA COMMITTEE. COMMITTEE
MEMBERS FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
TESTIFY TO TODAY. MY NAME'S
JOHN MCDERMOTT. ON A DIRECT ON
THE DIRECTOR OFENGINEERING AND
EXTERNAL AFFAIRS FOR LOTS
VIRGINIS MUNICIPAL WATER
DISTRICT. WE'RE A RETAIL WATER
AND WASTEWATER AGENCIES SERVING
APPROXIMATELY SEVENTY THOUSAND
RESIDENTS IN THE WESTERNMOST
PORTION OF LOS ANGELES COUNTY.
MY AGENCY WAS SEVERELY IMPACTED
BY THE DEVASTATING WAS A FIRE
IN LATE TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN
THAT SCORCHED TWO THIRDS OF OUR
ONE HUNDRED AND TWENTY SQUARE
MILE SERVICE AREA AND RESULTED
IN SEVERAL MILLION DOLLARS IN
DAMAGES TO OUR FACILITIES. NOT
TO MENTION THE HUNDREDS OF
CUSTOM TO FOSTER HOMES. THE
WILL BE FAR PROVIDED US WITH AN
IMPORTANT REMINDER OF THE NEED
TO INVEST AND RESILIENCY. FOR
DISASTERS WILDFIRES AND EVEN
PUBLIC SAFETY POWER SHUT OFF PS
PS EVENTS. WITHOUT ELECTRICITY
WATER UTILITIES CANNOT PUMP AND
TREAT WATER THAT IS ESSENTIAL
TO CUSTOMERS FOR HEALTH AND
SAFETY PURPOSES INCLUDING
COOKING CLEANING BATHING AND
SANITATION. THE GOAL OF WATER
AGENCIES IS TO MAINTAIN
CONTINUOUS SERVICE TO THE
CUSTOMERS AT ALL TIMES EVEN
DURING PS PS AMOUNTS. ELECTRIC
SERVICE FOR LVM W. D. IS
PROVIDED BY SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
EDISON. IN THE LAST YEAR LVM WD
HAS RECEIVED APPROXIMATELY
SIXTY SIX P. S. P. S. EVENT
NOTIFICATIONS WITH TEN EVENTS
THAT ACTUALLY RESULTED IN POWER
LOSS. IN THESE POWER LOSSES
WERE NOT NECESSARILY TO THE
ENTIRE SERVICER BUT AT LEAST
PORTIONS OF OUR SERVICE AREA.
OUR EXPERIENCE ESSENCE
NOTIFICATIONS ARE BOTH TIMELY
AND ACCURATE. HOWEVER WATER
AGENCIES FROM OTHER PARTS OF
THE STATE HAVE EXPRESSED
CONCERNS WITH THE AMOUNT OF
ADVANCE NOTICE PROVIDED FOR PS
PS EVENTS THE ACCURACY AND
GRANULARITY OF THE DATA
PROVIDED AND THE NEED FOR
BETTER NOTIFICATION ON SERVICE
RESTORATION. THIS FEEDBACK IN
THE CASE THAT THERE IS ROOM FOR
IMPROVEMENT. PS PS EVENTS
PRESENT A VARIETY OF
OPERATIONAL CHALLENGES FOR
WATER AGENCIES UPON
NOTIFICATION OF AN OF AN EVENT
WATER SYSTEM OPERATORS
TYPICALLY SWITCH THE PUMPS TO
MANUAL OPERATION MODE IN ORDER
TO TOP OFF THE WATER STORAGE
TANKS. THE HOLES IN THE TANKS
ARE NOT ALLOWED TO TREAT THE
NORMAL RANGE AND KEPT TO REMAIN
FULL OR NEAR FULL. TO BE SURE
THAT ADEQUATE WATERS OF IT
SHOULD A POWER SHUT OFF
ACTUALLY OCCUR. THIS PROCESS
CAN RESULT IN ADDITIONAL COSTS
FOR PUMPING DURING PEAK PERIODS
THAT ARE NORMALLY AVOIDED AND
FOR OVERTIME WIN STAFFER CALLED
OUT DURING NON WORKING HOURS.
WHEN ELECTRICITY IS CUT OFF TO
WATER SYSTEM OPERATORS MUST
ACTIVATE BACKUP POWER. SOURCES
INCLUDING OVERSEE BACKUP
GENERATORS. RELIEF REFILLING OF
GENERATORS AS NECESSARY AND
REQUIRES DALY SHUTTLING A FUEL
SUPPLIES. MECHANICS AND
ELECTRICIANS ALSO NEED TO BE
AVAILABLE ON STAND BY TO
ADDRESS FAILURES OR OTHER
PROBLEMS THAT CAN ARISE. FOR IS
PS FOUR IS PS PS OF ANTS LVM W.
D. WAS ABLE TO MAINTAIN
CONTINUOUS SERVICE TO ITS
CUSTOMERS WITH THE USE OF
EMERGENCY BACKUP GENERATORS
HOWEVER DURING THE WILL BE FAR
EL THE NWT EXPERIENCED A
GENERATOR FAILURE THAT
TEMPORARILY INTERRUPTED.
PUMPING OR PORTION OF A SERVICE
AREA CAUSING LOW WATER
PRESSURE. AND THE NEED TO ISSUE
A OF BOIL WATER NOTICE. TO
MAINTAIN CONTINUOUS SERVICE
DURING EMERGENCIES ANTI S. P.
S. EVENTS OF THE NWT AND WATER
AGENCIES THROUGHOUT THE STATE.
NEED TO INCREASE THEIR FOCUS.
ON RIGOROUS MAINTENANCE AND
TESTING OF A MERCY BACKUP
GENERATORS TO ENSURE THE
RELIABILITY. THE EQUIPMENT USED
TO BE EXERCISED. AND LOW TESTED
REGULARLY THROUGHOUT THE YEAR
IN ACCORDANCE WITH MANUFACTURE
RECOMMENDATIONS AND STANDARDS
ISSUED BY THE NATIONAL FIRE
PROTECTION AGENCY. HOWEVER
STRICT RUN TIME LIMITS
PRESCRIBED BY STATE AND LOCAL
AIR QUALITY REGULATIONS ARE A
BARRIER. FOR WATER UTILITIES TO
PREPARE AN OPERATOR GENERATORS
FOR POWER SHUT OFFS. ADDITIONAL
FLEXIBILITY IS NEEDED TO
MAINTAIN TESTING OPERATE
EMERGENCY BACKUP GENERATORS.
THIS IS WHY LV NWT IS CO
SPONSORING THE LEGISLATIVE
PROPOSAL WITH THE CALIFORNIA
MUNICIPAL UTILITY USE
ASSOCIATION THIS YEAR TO RELAX
SOME OF THE TESTING AND RUNTIME
RESTRICTIONS THAT CURRENTLY
SAYS SO THAT AGENCIES SUCH AS
OURS CAN AVOID COSTLY FARMS AND
FOR THE NEED TO REPLACE OLDER
GENERATORS WITH NEW GENERATORS.
AND UNNECESSARY AND COSTLY
ENDEAVOR. WATER AGENCIES ALSO
FACE FINANCIAL CHALLENGES TO
AFFECTING EFFECTIVELY PREPARE
FOR AND RESPOND TO PS PS
EVENTS. AS PREVIOUSLY MENTIONED
AGENCIES EXPERIENCED. INCREASED
OPERATING COSTS ASSOCIATE WITH
ADDITIONAL LABOR AND OVER TIME
EXPENDITURES EQUIPMENT RENTALS
PEAK PERIOD PUMPING FUEL
PURCHASES. E. S. P. S. OF
ANSWER KERN CONTRIBUTING TO THE
NEED FOR SIGNIFICANT CAPITAL
INVESTMENTS TO IMPROVE
RESILIENCY OF WATER SYSTEMS
DURING POWER OUTAGES. THESE
INVESTMENTS ARE NOT ONLY
INCLUDE THE PURCHASE OF NEW
PORTABLE EMERGENCY GENERATORS
WHICH ARE IN SHORT SUPPLY. BUT
ALSO UPGRADE OF FACILITIES TO
INCLUDE STATIONERY GENERATORS
AND OUT ANOTHER LOGICAL
UPGRADES. THE INVESTMENT
REQUIRED FOR OUR AGENCY ALONE
IS IN THE SEVERAL MILLIONS OF
DOLLARS. BY EXTRAPOLATING THIS
YOUR STATEWIDE THIS INVESTMENT.
NEED COULD POTENTIALLY EXCEEDS
SEVERAL HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS OF
DOLLARS. THIS YEAR'S PROPOSED
BUDGET INCLUDES FIFTY NINE AND
ONE TIME FUNDS TO SUPPORT
ADDITIONAL PREPAREDNESS SPECIAL
DISTRICTS SUCH AS OURS THE
PROVIDE CRITICAL CERTAIN
SERVICES. WERE INADVERTENTLY
LEFT OUT OF THIS YEAR'S CURRENT
BUDGET FOR FUNDING. IT'S
IMPORTANT TO REMEMBER THAT IT'S
NOT JUST AGENCIES COUNTY CITIES
THAT PROVIDE CRITICAL SERVICES
SPECIAL DISTRICTS ALSO PROVIDE
MUCH OF THE STATE'S CRITICAL
SERVICES OF ALL. IT'S A
POSITIVE STEP THAT WE ARE
INCLUDED IN THIS GO AROUND. SO
IN CONCLUSION ELECTRICAL
SERVICE PROVIDERS ARE IMPORTANT
UTILITY PARTNERS FOR WATER
AGENCIES. AND WE ARE COMMITTED
TO WORK WITH OUR HEWLETT
UTILITY COUNTERPARTS TO
IMPLEMENT PS PS EVENTS AFFECTED
EARLY. WE ALSO RECOGNIZE THAT
HE S. P. S. EVENTS ARE KEY
INTERIM MEASURE TO REDUCE THE
POTENTIAL FOR WILDFIRES. THAT
CAN BE CAUSED BY A DOWNED POWER
LINES HOWEVER PS PS ADVANCE
SHOULD NOT BE VIEWED AS A LONG
TERM SOLUTION. TO REDUCE THE
THREAT OF WHILE FAR UTILITIES
ACROSS THE STATE NEED TO MAKE
SIGNIFICANT INVESTMENTS TO
IMPROVE THE RESILIENCY.
ADDITIONAL FINANCIAL ASSISTANCE
FROM THE STATE IS NEEDED TO
ADDRESS P. S. P. S. RESILIENCY
FOR HER AND WASTE WATER
AGENCIES. MANY OF WHICH ARE
SPECIAL DISTRICT. THAT
CONCLUDES MY TESTIMONY WILL BE
HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS
YOU MIGHT HAVE A FEW WILL THANK
YOU PROCEED WITH THE NEXT
PRESENTER AND THEN SOME
QUESTIONS THE- AFTER THE THIRD
TO. THE DAY THANK YOU. A GOOD
MORNING CHAIR MEMBERS I'M
CLIFFORD JAN THE DIRECTOR OF
OPERATIONS AND MAINTENANCE FOR
THE EAST BAY MUNICIPAL UTILITY
DISTRICT. OR EAST BAY MUCH.
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
TO BE HEARD TODAY TO SHARE OUR
EXPERIENCES WITH THE PUBLIC
SAFETY POWER SHUT OFF LAST
FALL. BEFORE I GET INTO THE
DETAILS LET ME START BY SAYING
THAT EAST BAY MIGHT HAD NO
SERVICE INTERRUPTIONS TO OUR
WATER AND WAY FOR CUSTOMERS.
DURING LAST YEAR'S PS PS ONCE.
OUR SUCCESSFUL RESPONSE WITH
THE RESULT OF SIGNIFICANT
ADVANCE PREPARATION. EXTENSIVE
COMMUNICATION WITH OUR
CUSTOMERS PROACTIVE
COMMUNICATIONS WITH THE I. O.
U. AND COORDINATION EFFORTS
WITH ARMORED SEES RESPONSE
PARTNERS. ALL OF WHICH RESULTED
IN CONSIDERABLE COST IT BAY MUD
AND ITS RATEPAYERS I THINK ALL
OF YOU HAVE THEY HAD ALL IN
FRONT OF YOU LOOK AT THE FIRST
PAGE A HAND OUT I LIKE TO START
TO TELL YOU A LITTLE BIT ABOUT
EAST BAY MUD. WHERE THE SECOND
LARGEST WATER RETAILER IN
CALIFORNIA AND THE TWELFTH
LARGEST IN THE NATION. REVIVED
WATER PURPOSE TO OVER ONE FOUR
BILLION REPRESENTS. OUR SERVICE
AREA ENCOMPASSES THREE HUNDRED
THIRTY TWO SQUARE MILES AND
INCLUDES TWENTY CITIES AND
FIFTY ON IN CORPORATE IS IN
ALAMEDA AND CONTRA COSTA
COUNTIES. OR WORSE I FACILITIES
EXTEND FAR PRIMARY BARS I
RESERVOIR NINETY EAST. IN THE
FOOTHILL. YES THEY MIGHT ALSO
PER. WORKFORCE TOOK. SO HUNDRED
EIGHTY FIVE THOUSAND RESIDENTS
IT AND EIGHTY EIGHT SQUARE MILE
SERVICE AREA. MOVING TO THE
SECOND PAGE OF YOUR HAND OUT.
ON EAST BAY MUCH MORE SYSTEM IS
COMPLEX DUE TO ITS SIZE AND
TOPOGRAPHY. WE HAVE OVER FOUR
HUNDRED WATER FACILITIES ALL OF
WHICH CAN BE AFFECTED BY A PS
PS ABOUT. OUR SERVICE AREA
EXTENDS FROM SEA LEVEL TO ABOUT
A QUARTER OF A MILE IN
ELEVATION AND IS DIVIDED INTO
PRESSURES OWNS. WATER ME PUMPED
TO MANY OF OUR CUSTOMERS. IF
THEY MIGHT HAVE A HUNDRED
TWENTY TO ASSURE THAT. THE THIS
IN PERSPECTIVE SANFORD HAS TEN.
SO WHY ARE YES THE VENT A
CONCERN FOR EAST BAY MUD. FIRST
THE PRESSURIZATION IF WE CAN'T
PUMP WATER TORE STORAGE TANKS
THE WATER SYSTEM COULD
DEPRESSURIZED. A DEPRESSURIZED
SYSTEM CAN ALLOW EXTERNAL
CONTAMINANTS DRAW INTO THE
PIPES AND RESULT IN UNSAFE
WATER SUPPLY AND BOIL WATER
NOTICE AS- SECOND IF WE CAN'T
MAINTAIN PRESSURE WE WON'T BE
ABLE TO PROVIDE WATER FOR FIRE
FIGHTING. DURING UP YES YES
EVENT THERE CAN STILL BE
STRUCTURE FIRES IN OUR SERVICE
AREA. WE SAW THIS LAST OCTOBER
WHEN FIRE BROKE OUT IN CROCKETT
IN LAFAYETTE. MOVING TO THE
THIRD PAGE OF YOUR HAND OUT.
IT'S ALSO IMPORTANT TO
UNDERSTAND THE TIMELINE FOR PS
PS EVENT FROM A WATER UTILITIES
PERSPECTIVE. IT'S NOT JUST THE
HOURS OF THE ACTUAL SHOT OFF
BUT TE TIME BEFORE AND AFTER
THE OUTAGE. WHEN A PS PS OF IT
IS ANNOUNCED WE HAVE TO START
PAYING FOR EVENT INCLUDE
CONNECTING BACKUP EQUIPMENT. AT
THE AFFECTED FACILITIES. DURING
THE EVENT AND WHILE THE SYSTEM
IS BEING RE ENERGIZED WE HAVE
TO MONITOR SYSTEM IN IT ADMIN.
WHEN THE EVENT AND WE HAVE THE
MOBILE WHAT PARK MEANT. LOOK AT
LYME. TWENTY FOUR TO SEVEN TO
OUR PS PS AN ACTUALLY READ IN
SOME BETWEEN. TO NINE DAYS OF
IMPACT TO A WATER UTILITY.
MOVING TO LOS PAGER HAND OUT IN
TWENTY NINETEEN P. GINNY HAD A
P. S. P. S. EVENTS. FOR
POTENTIALLY AFFECTED EAST BAY
MODE FACILITIES. THE FIRST WAS
ON OCTOBER NINTH THAT AFFECTED
A HUNDRED THIRTY SIX OF OUR
FOUR HUNDRED PLUS FACILITIES
INCLUDING TWO WATER TREATMENT
PLANTS AND EIGHTY FOUR PUMPING
PLANTS AND RESERVOIRS. THE
SECOND ON OCTOBER TWENTY SIX
WAS THE LARGEST AND AFFECTED
TWO HUNDRED SIXTEEN FACILITIES
FOR WATER TREATMENT PLANTS AND
OVER A HUNDRED IMPLIES THE
RESERVOIRS. THIS PS PS OF ALSO
AFFECTED A NUMBER OF OUR UP
COUNTRY FACILITIES. THE LAST
TWO EVENTS WERE EVENTUALLY
CANCELED FOR OUR AREA. THE
TABLE BELOW ON THAT LAST PAGE
OF YOUR HAND OUT SHOWS THE
COSTS THAT WERE INCURRED DURING
THE OCTOBER CAST YES ABOUT.
THESE WERE SIGNIFICANT EXPENSES
THAT WERE NOT BUDGETED ARE
PLANNING RESPONSE MOUNTED TO
ALMOST ONE POINT FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS AND EVEN THOUGH THE
LAST TWO EVENTS WERE CANCELED
IT'S STILL COST US PREPARE AND
PLAN FOR POTENTIAL EVENTS. SO
WHAT BACK AND LOOKING AT WHY WE
WERE SUCCESSFUL ON THERE ARE
THREE REASONS WE PREPARED WE
ACTED AND WE COMMUNICATED A
LOT. OUR PREPARATION BEGIN IN
TWENTY EIGHTEEN. AND BUILT ON
OUR EXISTING EMERGENCY
PREPAREDNESS PROGRAM. WE
CONDUCTED TABLE TOP AND FIELD
EXERCISES RECORDED WITH CITIES
IN OUR SERVICE AREA AND COUNTY
EMERGENCY OPERATION CENTERS. WE
PREPARED A SPECIFIC MITIGATION
A RESPONSE PLAN FOR YES YES THE
VENTS. NOW EARLY OUR- WE LIST
AND STATE TWENTY NINE GENERATOR
IN ADVANCE OF THE TWENTY
NINETEEN WILDFIRE SEASON WHICH
WAS COSTLY AND NOT BUDGETED.
AND WE DEVELOPED SENSE OF
COMMUNICATION STRATEGY WE MET
WITH THE COMMUNITY AND OUR
NEIGHBORING UTILITIES WE
PREPARED MESSAGES IN ADVANCE TO
OUR EMPLOYEES ELECTED OFFICIALS
AND OUR CUSTOMERS. USE SOCIAL
MEDIA INCLUDING TWITTER AND
FACEBOOK AND TRADITION
TRADITIONAL NEWS MEDIA. WE
POSTED TIMELY INFORMATION ON
OUR WEBSITE. FOR BOTH EVENTS IN
OCTOBER WE SENT EMAILS TO OVER
SIX HUNDRED THOUSAND CUSTOMERS
AND NOTIFIED OVER TWO HUNDRED
THOUSAND RESIDENCES BY NEXT
DOOR. LASTLY WE WERE PERSISTENT
IN OUR EFFORTS TO COORDINATE
WITH THE I. O. U. LOOKING
FORWARD TO TWENTY TWENTY AND
BEYOND WE HAVE THREE MAIN
FOCUSES IN THE NEAR TERM. COST
REIMBURSEMENT BETTER
COMMUNICATION AND NEARING THE
SCOPE OF PS PS EVENTS. OUR
RESPONSE COSTS ARE NOT BUDGETED
AND ARE SIGNIFICANT. EAST BAY
MOD IS A PUBLIC AGENCY OUR
COSTS ARE BORNE BY RATE PAYERS
WHEN OUR COSTS GO UP OUR RATES
GO UP. IT WILL BE HELP. FOR THE
LAST TO CONSIDER EMBARRASSMENT
TO MINIMIZE IMPACTS OUR RATE
PAYERS. SECOND FREQUENT
COMMUNICATION AND INFORMATION
SHARING IS CRITICAL TO A
SUCCESSFUL RESPONSE PUBLIC
SAFETY PARTNERS LIKE EAST BAY
MUD SHOULD BE INCLUDED IN DALY
INSTANT BRIEFING CALLS CONVENE
BY I OWE YOU BEFORE AND DURING.
THIS EVENT. AND WE SEE MANY
ADVANTAGES TO EATING WITH THE
EYE ARE YOU AND OUR PUBLIC
SAFETY PARTNERS PRIOR TO THE
START OF EACH FIRE SEASON.
FINALLY WE BELIEVE A MORE
SURGICAL APPROACH. TO PS PS
OFFENSE IS NEEDED. THE PS PATH
EVENTS LAST FALL IN OUR SERVICE
AREA WE'RE VERY BROAD. WE HOPE
THERE'S A WAY TO LIMIT THE
SCOPE OF THE OUTAGES IN A MORE
TARGETED MANNER. THEY EVEN WITH
MORE SEARCH A SURGICAL APPROACH
WE CONTINUE TO NEED GENERATORS.
WHILE THE USE OF DIESEL
GENERATORS RUNS COUNTER TO OUR
AGGRESSIVE CLIMATE POLICIES AND
GREENHOUSE REDUCTION GOALS.
THERE IS IMPORTANT REALITY. WE
MUST HAVE RELIABLE BACKUP
ENERGY SOURCES AND THE SOURCE
NEEDS TO BE PORTABLE. SO THEY
CAN BE MOVED QUICKLY AND
RESPOND TO THE CHANGING
CONDITIONS. WE BELIEVE THAT PS
PS IS NOT A LONG TERM SOLUTION
AND WE HOPE TO CPS PS PHASED
OUT. AS FIFTY IMPROVEMENTS
ELECTRICAL ITEMS. TODAY FOR UP
TO. OR PERHAPS ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THE NEXT PRESENTER. GOOD
MORNING GARCIA VICE CHAIR TO
AND OF THE COMMITTEE. THANK YOU
FOR THE FOR FOCUSING THE
ATTENTION OF THIS COMMITTEE ON
THE IMPORTANT AS A P. S. P. S.
IMPACTS ON WATER AGENCIES. AS
MICHAEL MADE ON THE GENERAL
MANAGER CALAVERAS COUNTY WATER
DISTRICT- WE SERVE A RURAL AREA
ON THE EASTERN EDGE IT RANGES
FROM THE EASTERN EDGE OF THIS
YEAR AS OF THE WEST SLOPE SIDE
EASTER HAD TO THE CENTER. OF
THE WEST LOOP OF THE ERRORS. WE
TAKE SEPARATE DREAM PERSISTENCE
AND THIRTEEN WASTE WATER
FACILITIES WHERE PEAK P. GINNY
SERVICE TERRITORY AND WITHIN
THEIR TIER THREE AREA WHICH IS
CONSIDERED EXTREME RISK. WILD
FIRES A- LANDSCAPE DOLLARS. IN
INCLUDING TWENTY FIFTEEN FIRE
THAT WAS BY GINNY AND BURNED
OVER SO FIVE ACRE. EASY HAS
ENTERED FOR PS PS EVENTS WITH
THE FIRST OCCURRING IN OCTOBER
OF TWENTY EIGHTEEN. AND
RESPONSE TO WARNINGS FROM P.
GINNY. IN THE SPRING OF TWENTY
NINETEEN THE P. S. P. S. EVENTS
WOULD BE LARGER AND MORE
FREQUENT. CCW DEVELOPED AN
EMERGENCY ACTION PLAN SPECIFIC
TO P. S. P. S. EVENTS FROM MY
PERSPECTIVE A PS PS EVENT AS AN
EMERGENCY IN AND OF ITSELF
REGARDLESS OF WHETHER A FIRE
OCCURS. ARMOR AGENCY ACTION
PLAN CAN TELL DESCRIPTION BACK
UP GENERATORS AVAILABLE FOR
EACH FACILITY INCLUDING ONSITE
AND STAND BY GENERATION AND
PORTABLE TRAILER MOUNTED JENNER
IS THERE ARE BEING PARAMETERS
AND STATUS. IT ALSO INCLUDES
MUNITY OUTREACH EFFORTS AND
COORDINATION WITH EMERGENCY
RESPONSE AGENCIES AND OTHER
LOCAL AGENCY IN THE AREA. ALL
OF OUR GENERATORS ARE FUEL TO
HAS THERE CURRENTLY IS NO
PRACTICAL COST EFFECTIVE
ALTERNATIVE. OUR PS PS
EMERGENCY ACTION PLAN ALSO
CONTEMPLATES STAFFING OPTIONS
FOR THE SUBSTANTIAL REFUELING
EFFORT THAT IS REQUIRED DURING
PS. VENTS AND FOR A WASTE WATER
FACILITIES THAT MUST BE POPPED
USING A PUMP TRUCK THANK YOU
YES OF. WHAT WASTE WATER SPELLS
MANY OF OUR WASTE WATER LIFT
STATIONS ARE LOCATED NEAR LAKE
TALUK OR OTHER LOCAL WATER WAYS
THAT ALSO SERVED AS THE LOCAL
DRINKING WATER SUPPLY. IN ALL
SEASON HE HAS NEARLY EIGHTY
STAND BY AND PORTABLE
GENERATORS FOR A TREATMENT
PLANTS PUMP STATIONS SKATER
EQUIPMENT AND OTHER CRITICAL
FACILITIES THAT OTHERWISE WOULD
NOT FUNCTION WITHOUT P. GINNY
POWER. OUR GOAL IS TO PROVIDE
AN UNINTERRUPTED WATER AND
WASTEWATER SERVICE THROUGH THE
P. S. P. S. EVENTS. AND IT'S A
TESTAMENT TO OUR HARD WORKING
CREWS THAT DESPITE THE
DIFFICULTY OF OPERATING WATER
AND WASTEWATER FACILITIES
WITHOUT ELECTRICITY- OR AND
RUNNING ON BACKUP GENERATORS WE
HAVE NEARLY PERFECT RECORD. THE
FIRST PS PS SEVEN OCT IN. A
TWENTY EIGHTEEN ONLY AFFECTED A
SMALL SERVICE AREA BUT SERVE AS
A WARNING FOR WHAT WAS TO COME.
THE SECOND AND THIRD EVENTS IN
OCTOBER OF TWENTY NINETEEN.
AFFECTED ABOUT TWO THIRDS OF
OUR FACILITIES. WHICH STRAINED
OUR ABILITY TO MAINTAIN WATER
AND WASTEWATER SERVICE. THE
FOURTH EVENT TOOK ALL OF
CALAVERAS COUNTY OFFLINE
INCLUDING 1100% OF OUR
FACILITIES. IT WAS DURING THE
LAST. THIS LAST EVENT THAT WE
ARE FORCED INTERNET INTERRUPT
WATER SERVICE TO A SMALL NUMBER
OF CUSTOMERS. THE KEY POINT
THAT I WANT TO EMPHASIZE HERE
IS THAT P. S. P. S. EVENTS ARE
NOT THE SAME AS A TYPICAL POWER
OUTAGE. POWER OUTAGES OCCUR CAN
OCCUR ANY TIME AND FOR ANY
NUMBER OF REASONS. AND WE'RE
CERTAINLY NO STRANGER TO POWER
OUTAGES ESPECIALLY IN THE
HIGHER ELEVATIONS OF OUR OF OUR
COUNTY. THOSE OUTAGES HOWEVER
ARE TYPICALLY LIMITED IN
DURATION AND IN GEOGRAPHIC
SCOPE. YES YES EVENTS ARE AN
ENTIRELY DIFFERENT CREATURES
THAT HAVE FORCED US TO PURCHASE
NEW BACKUP GENERATORS AND
INSTALL ADDITIONAL FUEL STORAGE
CAPACITY THROUGHOUT OUR
DISTRICT. YES BECAUSE OF ITS
ALSO TEND TO IMPACT LARGE AREAS
WHICH MEANS THAT THE DEMAND FOR
FUEL AND FOR FEEL
TRANSPORTATION PEAKS AND
RESURGENT RENTAL GENERATORS ARE
SIMPLY NOT AVAILABLE. THE LACK
OF AVAILABILITY OF A RENTAL
GENERATOR IS NOT MERELY AN
INCONVENIENCE BUT IT CAN ALSO
MAKE OUR COMMUNITIES EXTREMELY
VULNERABLE TO CATASTROPHIC
WILDFIRE RISK. DURING THE FIRST
PS PS EVENT LAST YEAR. EARLY IN
THE MORNING OF OCTOBER TENTH
TWENTY NINETEEN THE SIX HUNDRED
KILOWATT BACKUP GENERATOR AT
FOR A COMPARABLE TREATMENT
PLANT FAILED. ARTS FOR THE
GENERATOR AND COULDN'T BE
COMPLETED FOR SEVERAL DAYS AND
WE ESTIMATED THAT ARE TREATED
WATER STORAGE WOULD LAST ABOUT
TWENTY FOUR HOURS. MORE
IMPORTANTLY AND I REALLY CAN'T
STRESS THIS ENOUGH BUT LIKE
MOST WATER SYSTEMS IN
CALIFORNIA THE FIRE HYDRANTS IN
COMPARABLE IS ALSO RELY ON THAT
TREATMENT PLANT AND THAT JUST
THAT SAME DISTRIBUTION SYSTEM
FOR WATER PRESSURE. SO WHILE
ARE TREATED WATER STORAGE WOULD
HAVE LASTED ABOUT TWENTY FOUR
HOURS SIMPLY FOR CONSUMPTIVE
PURPOSES IF A FIRE HAD BROKEN
OUT IN THAT COMMUNITY ON THAT
DAY. THE FIRE THE WITH THE
WATER WOULD NOT IT WOULD OUR
TANKS WERE DRAINED MUCH FASTER
THAN THAT. AND THAT'S IT THAT'S
ALL THERE IS FOR WHAT FOR FIRE
FIGHTING WATER IN THAT
COMMUNITY- THERE'S NO BACK UP
WATER SUPPLY FOR FIRE HYDRANTS.
AND THIS IS ON A DAY OF COURSE
THAT P. JEANNIE HAD DETERMINED
TO BE A RED FLAG WARNING. FOR
SEVERE WILDFIRE RISK. AND THE
HYDRANTS VERY WELL COULD HAVE
RUN DRY SHOULD HAVE FIRE OF
OCCURRED. AND THE CONSEQUENCES
IN CATASTROPHIC WE SOUNDED THE
ALARM TO EVERYONE WHO WOULD
LISTEN- EARLY THAT AFTERNOON
CALLOW YES WHO WOULD IT
CALAVERAS SO YES IS AND CAL
CALIFORNIA- YES AND SCOURED THE
STATE FOR GENERATORS INFORMED
US THAT THEY HAD FOUND A TWO
MEGAWATT TRAILER MOUNTED
GENERATOR THAT WAS THE ONLY ONE
THAT THEY COULD FIND IT WAS
AVAILABLE AND UNFORTUNATELY IT
WAS A TEXT AND- WOULDN'T BE
HERE IN TIME. OUR NOR RELIABLE
DOES RAIDER RENTAL VENDOR- TO
THE ONLY AVAIL AVAILABLE
GENERATOR THAT THEY COULD FIND
WAS AN EIGHTY TOTAL WATT
GENERATOR. AND SAN DIEGO WHICH
WAS NOT NEARLY LARGE ENOUGH OR
CLOSE ENOUGH. THE AVAILABILITY
BACKUP GENERATORS IS ONE OF THE
KEY DIFFERENCES BETWEEN P. S.
P. S. EVENTS AND A TYPICAL
POWER OUTAGE. IN THE END IT WAS
P. GINNY THAT EVENTUALLY CAME
THROUGH WE LEARNED THAT
AFTERNOON THE P. JEANNIE HAD
CONTRACTED WITH CERTAIN
GENERATOR VENDORS TO MAKE
BACKUP GENERATORS AVAILABLE. OF
FOR CRITICAL HEALTH AND SAFETY
EMERGENCIES A CONTRACTOR FOR P.
GINNY DELIVERED A SIX HUNDRED
KILOWATT GENERATOR THAT NIGHT
AND OUR TREATMENT PLANT BACK ON
LINE AROUND TEN PM. OUR PARENTS
AND PROP LAST YEAR. WE
HIGHLIGHTS THE VULNERABLE
POSITIONS OF OUR COMMUNITIES.
WHEN WATER AGENCIES ARE FORCED
TO OPERATE ON BACKUP GENERATORS
BUT IT ALSO PROVIDES A CASE
STUDY IN THE LIABILITY SHIFTING
THAT OCCURS DURING P. S. P.
EVENTS. DID YOU NEED THE OTHER
NOBODY'S IMPLEMENTING P. S. P.
S. IN PART TO REDUCE THEIR
EXPOSURE FROM LIABILITY TO
CATASTROPHIC WILDFIRES. FOR
THEIR SHORT SHAREHOLDERS AND
FOR THEIR BOTTOM LINE BUT THAT
LIABILITY DOESN'T DISAPPEAR IT
SHIFTS THE CHIPS TO. PUBLIC
AGENCIES IN THIS CASE. AND
CALVET AND CALIFORNIA WATER
AGENCIES FACE STRICT LIABILITY
FOR FIRE DAMAGE THAT OCCURS- IF
THE FIRE SPREADS AS A RESULT OF
LOS A PRESSURE OF FIRE HYDRANTS
EVEN IF THE WATER AGENCY WAS AT
NO FAULT AT ALL. SO IF A FIRE
HAD SPREAD. POPULOUS IN OCTOBER
TENTH LAST YEAR. THE LIABILITY
COULD WEAR IT VERY WELL HAVE
BEEN SEA CWD IN OUR RATE PAYERS
NOT BE GINNY. WHETHER OR NOT.
SUBJECT WATER AGENCIES DISTRICT
LIABILITY FOR FIRE DAMAGE. THAT
IS NOT THEIR FAULT IS A TOPIC
THAT DESERVES ITS OWN SEPARATE
HEARING BUT FOR THE IMMEDIATE
FUTURE I BELIEVE IT'S FAIR
TODAY AND MORE ASSISTANCE. FOR
CRITICAL PUBLIC INFRASTRUCTURE
FROM INVESTOR OWNED UTILITIES.
THEIR BOTTOM LINE IMPROVES BY
SHIFTING ABILITY FROM THEM ON
TO US. AND WE ARE NOT EQUIPPED
FOR FREQUENT ALONG TO PSP S.
EVENTS. WE NEED MORE
GENERATORS. AND WE NEED
FINANCIAL ASSISTANCE FOR THE
RULE OVER TIME BECAUSE- AND THE
COST ASSOCIATED WITH. YES IN
ADDITION TO GENERATORS.
RESOURCES WE SHOULD EMPLOY THE
I USED TO FOCUS THEIR
INVESTMENT IN HARDENING THEIR
INFRASTRUCTURE ON THE CIRCUITS
THAT SERVE THE CRITICAL PUBLIC
INFRASTRUCTURE SUCH AS
HOSPITALS PUBLIC SAFETY AND
WATER. FOCUSING EFFORTS ON
THOSE SIR COULD REDUCE THE
DOWNTIME FOR A CRITICAL PUBLIC
INFRASTRUCTURE. THANK YOU AGAIN
FOR THE OPERA OPPORTUNITY TO
TESTIFY TODAY AND I WELCOME ANY
QUESTIONS THE COMMITTEE. I
THANK YOUNG OPEN IT UP TO FROM
MY COLLEAGUES. QUESTION AT
THANK YOU FOR THAT DETAILED
INFORMATION AND THANK YOU TO
THE EAST BAY FOR THE NUMBERS TO
HELPS BRING IT IN PERSPECTIVE-
WE JUST HEARD ABOUT THE IDEA OF
REQUIRING THE LEAST PAY FOR
SOME OF THESE COSTS ARE ALL OF
THESE COSTS IN IT I THINK
YOU'RE THE EP MADE A COM AT THE
STATE HELPING WITH THESE COSTS
IS THAT YOUR HOPE. I'LL AT THE
STATE WILL HELP MAN. SEE LIKE
MY BUTLER TO. PROPOSED YEAH I'M
NOT I THINK THERE'S A BIRTHDAY
TO LOOK AT THIS BUT YOU KNOW
ONE POSSIBILITY IS FOR THE I.
O. U. S. TO REIMBURSE THE
UTILITIES OF OUR UTILITIES FOR
THE COSTS THAT WE IN HER. AND
THEN MY OTHER QUESTION WITH HE-
IF YOU'RE FACILITIES RUNNING
LIKE IT'S NORMALLY DO TO RUN.
VERSUS WHEN WE HAVE ALL THESE
DIESEL OUR GENERATORS I'M JUST
CURIOUS ABOUT. DO WE HAVE A LOT
MORE EMISSIONS ARE TALKING
ABOUT AS WELL AND THERE IS A
LOT MORE PARTICULAR MATTER
CARBON AND SO FORTH TO THESE
COMMUNITIES. AND DO WE HAVE A
LOT OF RESIDENTS IN THERE SO
FORTH AND JUST KIND OF CURIOUS
ABOUT WHAT HAPPENED STARK WALL
OVER. TO FIND THE PROBLEM. YOU
KNOW THAT. CRITICAL ISSUE AND
AN MORE URBAN A BUT IT IT
CERTAINLY IS AN ISSUE FOR US AS
WELL AND NOT JUST THE IMMEDIATE
PUBLIC HEALTH IMPACTS BUT ALSO
OBVIOUSLY- EMITTING MORE
GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS AND
ANY OF US WOULD LIKE- AND
THAT'S NOT A SITUATION I DON'T
THINK ANY WATER AGENCY WANTS TO
BE ME- RUNNING THERE IS OFTEN
DIESEL DIESEL GENERATORS- BUT
THERE REALLY IS NO CURRENT THE
ALTAR TO THAT AT THAT THIS TIME
IN AND- YOUR PRE POINT. THANK
EITHER OR BOTH. IT'S ALL. I
BELIEVE THAT THE I. O. U.'S
SHOULD SHARE THE COST OF THIS
RISK OF THESE IMPACT BUT WHAT
THE STATE MAKING GRANT MONEY
AVAILABLE IN THE NEAR TERM
WOULD ALSO BE INCREDIBLY
HELPFUL AND ESPECIALLY- MAKING
SURE TO OPEN THAT GRANT THOSE
GRANT FUNDS UP TO SPECIAL
DISTRICTS IN ADDITION TO CITIES
AND COUNTIES. AND ONE OTHER
QUESTION FOR THE EAST BAY SO
THESE THESE NUMBERS ARE.
HELPFUL TO PURCHASE THESE TWO
INCIDENCES. THEY HAD A HERO. WE
HAVE A BUT THE MY LOOK LIKE IF
IT AS THE GETS PASSED TO THE
RATE PAYERS LIKE ARE WE TALKING
ABOUT A COUPLE DOLLARS FOR EACH
OF THESE INCIDENTS ARE TALKING
ABOUT. BUT I CAN SPEAK TO IN
TERMS OF UP PERCENT RATE
INCREASE SO- ONE POINT FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS A YEAR ON THE
OPERATING COSTS REPRESENTS
ABOUT A POINT 3% RATE INCREASE
FOR OUR WATER CUSTOMERS- ON AN
ANNUAL BASIS. THANK YOU. IF YOU
DON'T MIND AGAIN A SIMILAR
LIMITED LIKE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
ANSWER THAT SAME QUESTION
BECAUSE FOR MUCH SMALLER THE
NEWSPAPER BUT OBVIOUSLY- AND
FOR. US THAT TO OF THE TOTAL
COST LAST YEAR NOT INCLUDING
PURCHASING NEW GENERATORS CAME
TO ABOUT TWO HUNDRED FIFTY
THOUSAND DOLLARS- FOR US OF
WHAT PERCENT INCREASE IT. ON
WASTE WATER RATES IS ABOUT A
HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS. SO
IT'S A IT'S A PRETTY
SIGNIFICANT IMPACT FOR OUR
OPERATING BUDGET THAT THAT WE
ALSO DIDN'T BUDGET FOR. AND
HAVING TO BUDGET FOR THAT GOING
FORWARD. IS ESSENTIAL. OF THE
INCREASE WE HAD A SCHEDULED.
JUST FORTY. S. THANK YOU. MAY
YOU. THE QUICK QUESTION FOR YOU
THREE OF IS YOUR ANTI SERVER
CENTER SERVICE AREAS BY P.
JEANNIE WITHIN THE SPACE IN TO.
JUST JUSTIN IS BACK. THANK
THANK YOU THE QUESTIONS. THIS
IS SO YOU ARE. MOSTLY FROM
WATER DISTRICTS SO OTHER THAN
IS A MUD IS INCLUDING. HOWEVER
ELECTRICITY'S UNDER YOU WILL
JURISDICTION. IT IS SPACE ARE
NOT JUST THE WATER WHY IS SO A
LUXURY CITY AS WELL. WE OUR
WATER AND WASTEWATER UTILITY WE
DO TO GENERATE POWER- ARE UP
COUNTRY FACILITIES THAT WE SELL
BUT WE DON'T WE DON'T SELF
SERVE ANY OF OUR POWER- EXCEPT
FOR OUR WASTE MARK. CAN SELF
SERVE SOME POWER. WE DO HAVE
SOME- AFFORDABLE TEXT AT SOME
FACILITIES THAT CAN OFFSET SOME
OF OUR LOAD- BUT NOT THE LOAD
ENTIRELY. MRS SO YOU COULD WITH
ENOUGH. I HEARD. THERE IS A
SOME. BUSINESS MODELER A
COMPANY IS A PROPOSED LETTER
KNOW WHETHER YOU HEARD ABOUT IT
THE SINCE MANY HOMES ARE ARE
USING SOLAR PANEL. IS SET GROUP
DISTRICT OR EVEN HOMEOWNERS
ASSOCIATION OR CD COULD.
DEVELOPER A SYSTEM THAT THE-
THEY TIME REGULAR TIME ENERGY
EXCESS ENERGY CAN BE STORED. IN
THE BATTERY. AND THE BATTERY
SYSTEMS OR BE ORDER. CONNECTED
AND IT BECOMES A SHOE WHICH
ENERGY SOURCE. FOR EMERGENCY
SITUATIONS HAVE YOU HEARD ABOUT
IT WILL IS TO ME THAT IS A
EXCELLENT IDEA RATHER THAT
USERS. THE BOTTOM PORTABILITY
AND THE LIMITED AND THEN ALSO.
IN ALMOST WONDERING IN WHAT
KIND OF A POLLUTION IT IT
GENERATES- IF FOR SO MANY
GENERATORS SAW. IN A WIN
CALIFORNIA A SO SENSITIVE TO
ENVIRONMENTAL ISSUES SO I THINK
GOOD THIS. IDEA OF A CONNECTING
THE NETWORK OF A STORAGE
ELECTRICITY STORAGES SYSTEMS
THAT THE EACH HOUSE WOULD HAVE
I HAVE A SOLAR SYSTEM BUT I
DON'T HAVE SOLAR BATTERY. MAY
BE THE STATE. CAN PROVIDE THE
SOME INCENTIVES OF FOUR OR
HOMES TO HAVE FULL.
ELECTRICITY'S STORAGE BATTERY
SYSTEMS. AND IN EMERGENCY
SITUATION AND THAT PARTICULAR
AREA IF THIS A HOMEOWNERS
ASSOCIATION OR CD OR UTILITY
DISTRICT. OUT WOULD HAVE WHAT
ORDER POWELL CONNECTED AND DO
YOU HAVE EXCESS POWER YOU CAN
USE TO THE FULL WATER PUMPING
ETCETERA YEAH I YEAH I THINK
THE IDEA OF THE MICROGROOVE
SOME IT CERTAINLY IS A
POSSIBILITY AND IF AN I OR YOU
CAN EFFECTIVELY IMPLEMENT A
SOLUTION LIKE THAT- WITH THE WE
ARE GRATEFUL FOR THEM TO DO
THAT WE DID LOOK AT YOUR
WEATHER OR NOT- ABOUT. HIS
BIGGEST. IS A FEW INCHES WE-
ARE FIRST WHAT IS VERY HEAVY
OBJECT TO PAY IN PER. EVERY DAY
BAY MY MOVED ONE POINT THREE
BILL POUNDS WATER. WE LOOK OUR
FACILITIES ARE PUMP FACILITIES
THERE'S NOT A LOT OF SPACE
THESE AREN'T VERY LARGE
FACILITIES SO WHEN WE SCOPED
OUT ON TV SYSTEM. TV PANELS.
WOULD COVER AN AREA MUCH LARGER
THAN THE PROPERTY THAT WE
ACTUALLY OWN- IN ADDITION- YOU
HAVE THE BATTERY SO YOU NEED A
SYSTEM THAT CAN CHARGE THE
BATTERIES DURING THE DAY. AND
OPERATE YOUR PUMPS AT NIGHT ON
THESE PUMPS ARE FAIRLY LARGE TO
MOVE THE AMOUNT OF WATER IN OUR
SPACE IS LIMITED SO FOR A
UTILITY TO IMPLEMENT PUSH LIKE
THAT- IF EITHER ON JUST NOT
POSSIBLE BECAUSE WE DON'T HAVE
THE SPACE- BUT MAYBE YOU TO.
BYE HE JIMMY. THERE ARE MICRO
GRADES AND SUPPLY MORE RELIABLE
POWER BUT FROM OUR PERSPECTIVE
WE ACTUALLY DON'T HAVE THE
SPACE- OR THAT AND COSTS ARE
PRETTY HIGH TO IMPLEMENT A- SO.
I THINK COME MY BEST. I'D LIKE
CAN I CAN I AM TO THAT THAT
WOULD IS A NICE NEW TO ME IS A
VERY LISTENING TO THE I RIGHT
NOW. THE EMERGENCY SAYS SO YOU
pSOURCES TWO OF SUPPLY WATER AND
I THINK ENERGY SOURCE OF WE HAD
TO WE RELY ON THEM WHEN THE
PIZZA THE GENERATOR'S GO UP
THIS KIND OF WORK. THE NEW
SYSTEM MAY IN A CALL THE- AS
SHOWN PANEL NO AS ALMOST ALL OF.
IMAGE MACROS. OR NETWORK SYSTEM
OR WHATEVER NAME WE CAN COME UP
WITH A IN A I FEEL THAT HAS A
SOME POTENTIAL TO ME. I'M A
DIRECTLY I'LL JUST ECHO A LOT
OF WITH MY COLLEAGUES HERE JUST
MENTION BUT- BY I DO BELIEVE
THAT THE TECHNOLOGY HAS COME A
LONG WAYS- IN RECENT YEARS AS
FAR AS- STORAGE AND THOSE SORTS
OF THINGS BATTERY STORAGE FOR
THE INDIVIDUAL HOMEOWNER. THE
POWER REQUIRE IS FOR WATER
WASTEWATER UTILITIES IS
ABSOLUTELY ENORMOUS- IN
COMPARISON. AND JUST TO GIVE
YOU SOME INSIGHT WE ACTUALLY OF
THE NWT HOUSE A ONE MEGAWATT
SOLAR. FARM OBVIOUSLY IT
DOESN'T PRODUCE ANY ELECTRICITY
AT NIGHT SO THAT'S A PROBLEM IF
YOU HAVE IF YOU HAVE A-
PROLONGED KISS PIASTRE OF AN
OUTAGE FOR. A DAY OR LONGER SO
THAT'S PROBLEMATIC THERE AND
LEADS TO THE NEED FOR YOU KNOW
A BATTERY BACKUP. THE THIS SO
SOLAR FOR. ENOUGH POWER FOR ONE
POP. ONE STE IT'S A ONE
MEGAWATT TAKES UP FIVE ACRES.
AND WE HAVE DOZENS AND DOZENS
OF PALM THROUGHOUT A HUNDRED
TWENTY SQUARE MILE SERVICE AREA
SO THE ONLY PRACTICAL BACK UP
POWER FOR UTILITIES AT THIS
POINT IS DIESEL GENERATION. I'D
I COMPLETELY AGREE THAT IT IS
MUCH AS WE WOULD LOVE TO HAVE A
BROTHER RELIABLE MICHAEL GRADE
SOLUTION AVAILABLE TO US WAS
CLEANER IT'S THE STATE A
TECHNOLOGY RIGHT NOW IS SIMPLY
NOT THERE IT'S NOT PRACTICAL
IT'S NOT EFFECTIVE AND THE AND
YOU SIMPLY. ESPECIALLY FOR. AN
ARTS IN OURWE HAVE FACILITIES
SPREAD THROUGHOUT THE THOUSAND
MILE. SQUARE MILE COUNTY- WITH
WITH A RELATIVELY SMALL
COMPARED LIAM RELATIVELY SMALL
NUMBER OF RATEPAYERS. AND THE
COST OF TRYING TO FIND A MIKE
GETS SENT TO ALL OF THOSE
FACILITIES- IT JUST IT JUST
UNFORTUNATELY IS NOT PRACTICAL.%
RIGHT PLEASE. SO DURING THE PS
PS IS ARE YOU FACED WITH FINES
RIGHT NOW AND RUN TIME.
RESTRICTIONS DOES THAT. ABOUT
SO L. B. M. W. D. WE HAVE NOT.
BEEN SUBJECT TO ANY FINES
FORTUNATELY WE'VE COME CLOSE.
THE TO SPEAK TO THE RUN TIME
RESTRICTIONS- OLDER GENERATORS
TO DEPENDS ON THE SIZE AND HOW
OLD THE GENERATOR IS AND WHAT
CLASS RAN. WE HAVE A TWENTY
HOUR PER YEAR MAXIMUM RUNTIME
FOR MAINTENANCE PURPOSES JUST
TO MAKE SURE IT'S GONNA BE
OPERATIONAL WHEN THERE IS AN
EMERGENCY. SO WE'VE MANAGED TO
AVOID FINES ASSOCIATED WITH
THAT WE DESPERATELY NEED LONGER
RUN TIME FOR TESTING AND
MAINTENANCE AND THAT'S PART OF
OUR LEGISLATIVE PROPOSAL. AS
FAR AS ACTUAL EMERGENCY WILL
SEE WE IN OUR SITUATION THE ONE
LOOK THE ONE FACILITY THAT. WE
LOST POWER FROM LIKE RED FOR A
PROLONGED PERIOD TIME. A IN HIS
OLDER GENERATORS THERE'S A TWO
HUNDRED HOUR MAX RUNTIME CáC.
THIS PARTICULAR FACILITY
FORTUNATELY WE GOT A MOBILE
GENERATOR THAT WAS. PERMITTED
THROUGH- AT THE STATE LEVEL SO
NOT THROUGH THE LOCAL REGIONAL
AIR QUALITY CONTROL BOARD DOWN
SOUTH- BUT SO FORTUNATELY WERE
ABLE TO GET A GENERATOR RUN THE
FACILITY THAT TILL HE WAS DOWN
SIX. WHICH FAR AS TO HUNDRED
HOURS. SO IT'S JUST SOMETHING
TO KEEP IN MIND THERE IS A LOT
OF COMPLICATIONS WITH. WITH
THESE GENERATORS AND JUST SOME
OF THE RESTRICTIONS THAT WERE
FACED WITH. Q. I DO HAVE A
COUPLE QUESTIONS IN ALL START
WITH THE MICHAEL OF KIND OF
WITH A CONTRAST TO THE
CHALLENGES THAT MAY BE THE
BIGGER URBAN AREAS HAVE VERSUS
SOME OF THE MORE RURAL AREAS
CAN YOU MAYBE HIGHLIGHTS SOME
OF THOSE CHALLENGES THAT YOU
SEE BEFORE YOU THAT ARE A BIT
DIFFERENT. HI THE BROKEN UNITY
CHALLENGES AGAINST AND YOU
MENTIONED SOME OF COSTS RIGHT
AND- BEING ABLE TO KIND OF
SPREAD THAT DROP OUT BUT- ARE
THERE ANY OTHER. AREAS A YUBA
COULD POTENTIALLY HIGHLIGHT
THAT WOULD REFLECT OTHER WATER
AGENCIES AND FIND THEMSELVES IN
MORE RURAL PARTS OF THE STATE.
IT COST IS DEFINITELY A BIG
ONE- ALTHOUGH IN THIS CASE I AT
A LOT OF THE EXAMPLES THAT MY
COLLEAGUES HAVE MENTIONED SOUND
VERY FAMILIAR TO ME WE'VE WE'VE
WE'VE HAD ALSO. HOW WE MAINTAIN
AND OPERATE. OUR GENERATOR- A
LOT OF THE SAME EXPERIENCES- I
WOULD SAY THE OTHER CHALLENGE
FOR US STAFFING WE HAVEN'T.
COMPLY OUR OUR FULL TIME STAFF
IS SIXTY SIX EMPLOYEES. ABOUT
FORTY FIVE OF THOSE ARE
OPERATIONAL- AND THE EFFORT
THAT WOULD STICK BALL CAN KEEP
ALL OF OUR GENERATORS FUELED.
PUMPING NOW ALL OF OUR WASTE
WATER. IT PUTS AN INCREASE. IN
ON A VERY SMALL NUMBER OF YOUR
MAKE AND ELECT. AND THAT WE
HAVE AND SO THEY ENDED UP
WORKING EXTREMELY LONG DAYS-
DURING THESE P. S. P. S. EVENTS
AND SO NOT ONLY THE OVERTIME
COSTS TO THE DISTRICT- BUT IT
AT A CERTAIN POINT YOU START TO
WORRY ABOUT SAFETY. AND THE
IMPACT ON YOUR CRUISE. IT EAST
BAY THE MEAN. UTILITIES ANY ERA
OTHER IT. LONG TERM INVESTMENTS
THAT- THE AGENCY HAS BEEN
MAKING ARE. PROJECTING TO MAKE.
RELEVANT TO THE SUBJECT AT HAND.
YEAH I MEAN I THINK YOU'RE
WORTH CERTAINLY LOOK AT ALL OUR
PUMP STATIONS WE DO HAVE
PERMANENT BACKUP POWER AT ALL
OF OUR TREATMENT PLANTS IN OUR
MAJOR PUMPING PLANTS- AND YOUR
WE DIDN'T KNOW GOING INTO THE
TWENTY THAT LAST YEAR'S YES PS
WHAT TO EXPECT FROM PEACE IN A-
DID A LOT ANALYSIS TO
UNDERSTAND WHAT THE IN. WOULD
BE POWER OUTAGES AND I THINK
IT'S CERTAINLY HIGHLIGHTED
CERTAIN FACILITIES THAT WE
MIGHT WANT TO INSTALL PERMANENT
BACKUP POWER OUT- BUT WE STILL
BELIEVE THAT FLEXIBILITY IT'S
ALL JUST BETWEEN THE OCTOBER
NINTH IN THE OCTOBER TWENTY.
THE CONDITIONS CAN CHANGE QUICK.
WE HAVE TO HAVE THE ABILITY TO
BE VERY NIMBLE AND MOVE
EQUIPMENT AROUND- THE RISK OF
INSTALLING PERMANENT. PORTABLE
POWER IS THAT WE CAN'T MOVE
PERMANENT PARTIAL POWER.
PERMITTED POWER AROUND SO WE DO
NEED THAT TYPE OF FLEXIBILITY
BUT THERE ARE CERTAIN AREAS
WERE WILL PROBABLY INVEST.
PERMANENT POWER. QUESTION FOR
ANY AND ALL. OF THE SOME OF
THESE ON THE PREVENTIVA SIDE
FROM STATE ARE THERE SPECIFIC
UP PROGRAMS POTS OF MONEY THAT
YOU LOOKED AT IN OF SOUL WHAT
ARE THE- DIFFICULT TO ACCESS
AND THAT WOULD CARRY WE WERE
TALKING ABOUT MORE RESOURCES
ACROSS THE BALLROOM HAVE THIS
CONVERSATION BUT- CIVIC
PROGRAMS ALREADY. OUT THERE
THAT THEY WILL TAKE A LOOK AT A
TO BE ABLE TO CONSIDER
ENHANCING THOSE- BUDGETARY.
LINE ITEMS OR ARE THERE
CHALLENGES EVEN FOR THAT MATTER
ACCESSING THOSE PROGRAMS
WHETHER BE A SMALLER ROLE. FOR
THAT MATTER. SOME OF THE MORE
URBANIZED THAT WATER AGENCIES.
THE ONE THAT COMES AMONG THE IS
IT. THE SEVENTY FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS AT THE GOVERNOR'S BALL.
INCLUDED LAST YEAR- FOR PS PS
RESPONSE WITH LIMITED TO CITIES
AND COUNTIES- TO DISTRICTS NOT
ABLE TO LIVE FOR THAT MAY OKAY.
THIS UNDER IS. THAT THEY HAVE
BEEN A GOV PROPOSED BUDGET IN
ITS WITH A FIFTY NINE DOLLARS
FOR P. PS. OPEN SPECIAL. IN
THAT SAME- PART OF MONEY SO- IN
MY OPINION I THINK FIFTY
MILLION DOLLARS IS GOING TO GO
VERY QUICKLY AND THEN THAT. I
THINK IT WOULD BE. A GOOD- USE
OF RESOURCES TO INCREASE THAT
THAT. IN THE BUDGET WHO KNOWS.
THAT WELL I'M I'M AWARE SOME
FUNNY AND GRANT FUNDING THROUGH
FEMA- WHICH IS OBVIOUSLY NOT
THE STATE LEVEL SO WE'VE WE'VE
BEEN SEEKING OUT SOME OF THAT
WE ARE ACTUALLY INSTALLING
SEVERAL FIX EMERGENCY
GENERATORS THAT ARE MORE
CRITICAL FACILITIES AND- WE ARE
ACTUALLY BANG OR TOLL REFORM.
IT GAVE MEGAWATT SOME ANOTHER
TWENTY. BUT AGAIN THAT THAT HAS
LIMITATIONS. YEAH I WOULD JUST
ADD I MEAN THE TYPE BUT MICHAEL
TALK ABOUT WE DID APPLY FOR A
DEMOCRAT AND WE WERE- IT WAS
DENIED. OKAY I DON'T HAVE ANY
OTHER QUESTIONS THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR BEING HERE AGAIN. WITH
US AND PROVIDE INSERT VERY
CRITICAL INFORMATION TO US
THANK YOU. WILL CALL THE- PANEL
AND THE FINAL- PRESENTATIONS
FOR THIS HEARING- LISA. HE
REGION- FOR CARE THE CALIFORNIA
WATER AND WASTEWATER AGENCY
RESPONSE NETWORK. THE PROGRAM
MANAGER FOR THE CITY OF
SACRAMENTO DEPARTMENT OF
UTILITIES WELCOME. AND JULIE
BISHOP PAUL SENIOR LEGISLATIVE
ADVOCATE- FOR THE ASSOCIATION
OF CALIFORNIAWATER AGENCIES
THAT YOU MAY BEGIN YOUR
PRESENTATION WHEN YOU'RE READY.
GOOD MORNING AND THANK YOU FOR
LETTING ME TALK TO YOU A LITTLE
BIT ABOUT CAL WARRANT AND HOW
IT BENEFITS THE P. S. P. S. AS
WELL AS ITS RECENT USE IN THE
CALIFORNIA FIRE. TAKE AWAY FROM
TODAY PRESENTATION IS IT IS
THAT. CAL WARREN CAN SPEED UP
THE PROCESSFOR EMERGENCY
ASSISTANCE STREAMLINE IT AND
YOU CAN AT SAID AB REQUEST CAL
WARN IF YOU'RE A MEMBER. FOR
ANYTHING OTHER IT DOESN'T HAVE
TO BE AN EMERGENCY. MY NAME IS
LISA THE SKI AND I'VE BEEN WITH
THE CITY OF SACRAMENTO UTILITY
APARTMENT FOR SIX YEAR I
CURRENTLY A STEERING. MAY
MARIN. AND HAVE SOME OF THE
PAST THREE YEARS. GIVEN
INSTRUCTION AND UP AS
INDICATIONS REGARDING HOW WORN.
SO WHAT IS MORNING. MARIN IS
THE CALIFORNIA WITH WATER. HE
WAS NETWORK. IT'S MADE UP. FOR
A UTILITY AN DIFFERENT AGENTS.
AND THEY HAVE SUCH A COLLECTIVE
OF. HE MET FOR ME THEY TOOL.
IT'S HOW WARNED OF A UP THIS OF
CALIFORNIA FOR AND TO FIVE
REGIONS I HAPPEN TO BE THE
CHAIR FOR REGION FOUR WHICH
EXTENDS FROM THE NORTH NUMBER
THAT A COUNTY TO THE SOUTH OF
STANISLAUS- WEST IS YELLOW AND
THEN EAST TO HELP. THERE ARE
ALSO. WARNED OFF STATES
INCLUDING CANADA AND MEXICO AS
WELL. I MENTIONED EARLIER TO
THE BENEFITS THAT I HOPE YOU
TAKE AWAY TODAY IS- TO
STREAMLINE THE PROCESS FOR
EMERGENCY ASSISTANCE THROUGH
CAL WORN AS BEING A MEMBER AS
WELL AS OF THAT YOU CAN REQUEST
CAL WORN DENTS EVEN IF IT ISN'T
AN EMERGENCY I'D LIKE TO GO
THROUGH EACH OF THOSE A LITTLE
BIT IN DETAIL. FOR THE FIRST
ONE THE EMERGENCY ASSISTANCE A
STREAMLINING IN THE NORMAL
PROCESSES A WATER AGENCY WOULD
UTILIZE THEIR SERVICES. I USE
ALL THE RESOURCES AND THEN
THEY'D REACH OUT FOR THE CITY.
AND THEN THEY REACH OUT TO THE
COUNTY AND THE STATE AND THE
FEDS AND GENERALLY AND ALL OF
THAT THERE HAS TO BE SOME SORT
OF DECLARATION OF AN EMERGENCY.
CAL RAN BOMB ALL WATER AGENCY
HOW DO IS GO TO THE WEBSITE
WHICH IS W. W. W. DOT CAL
WARNED DOT ORG- THEY WOULD
REACH OUT TO A CHAIR IT DOESN'T
HAVE TO BE THE CHAIR IN THE
REGION. IT'S SUGGESTED THAT IT
IS BUT IT DOES TO BE. THEY
REACH OUT TO A CHAIR AND THE
CHAIR AND THE- REQUESTING
AGENCY WOULD WORK ON TYPE OF
ASSISTANCE IS NEEDED. AND DATES
THAT ASSIST THROUGH THE OF
NUMBER LET ME GIVE YOU AN IN.
OF HOW QUICKLY THAT WORKED WITH
THE- CALIFORNIA EXCUSE ME THE
NAPA EARTHQUAKE SO THAT WOULD
BE. THE PAGE THAT STATES CAO
WARNED SUPPORT TO NAPA
EARTHQUAKE. SO THIS IS A TIME
LINE RESPONSE WITH CAL WORN. I
WON'T GO THROUGH EVERY SINGLE
ENTRY BUT I'LL JUST HIGHLIGHTED
FUSE SO THE- UP WORTH QUAKE
OCCURRED ON AUGUST TWENTY
FOURTH TWO THOUSAND FOURTEEN AT
THREE TWENTY IN THE MORNING- OF
TEXT MESSAGE WAS REACHED OUT TO
THE MAYOR OF THE CITY OF NAPA.
TO SEE IF THEY NEED ASSISTANCE
CALIFORNIA THEY AT THAT POINT
THEY HADN'T ASSESS THE DAMAGES
BUT IF YOU LOOK DOWN TO ABOUT
NINE FIFTY FIVE. THANK FOR. WAS
REQUEST. TO THE PERSON THAT
REACHED OUT FROM THE CITY OF
NAPA AND BETWEEN- WHEN A I'M
AND SIX THIRTY PM. A CONFERENCE
CALLS WERE PUT TOGETHER WITH
THE CAL WORN MEMBERS TO FIGURE
OUT THE TYPE OF ASSISTANCE THAT
THEY CAN HELP OUT NAPA. AND BY
SEVEN THIRTY THAT IGHT THEY
HAD FIVE MUTUAL ASSISTANCE
CREWS FROM THREE DIFFERENT
AGENCIES READY TO DEPLOY THEM
STAY. LESS THAN TWENTY FOUR
HOURS HE HAD SAID THEY NEEDED.
HE OTHER I'D THE BENEFIT OF
BEING A COW WORN MEMBER IS THAT
IN THE CASE OF A NON EMERGENCY
SITUATION. DURING THE P. S. P.
S. SHUT OFFS IN OCTOBER WE HAD
READ A SEVERAL AGENCIES REACHED
OUT TO THE CITY OF SACRAMENTO-
TO UP A REQUEST ASSISTANCE FOR
POSSIBLE GENERATORS ONE OF THEM
WAS HIDDEN VALLEY LAKES. AND WE
HAD SET UP A- AGREEMENT RIGHT
THEN AND THERE AND SO BY THE
TIME THEY NEEDED THAT BACK IN
OCTOBER. CONTACTED ME AND
WITHIN MORNING TO THE NEW. AT
ODD GENERATORS WILL WERE SENT
BEING SENT ON THEIR WAY TO
HIDDEN VALLEY SO AGAIN-
STREAMLINED PROCESS BUT IT
DOESN'T NEED TO BE AN EMERGENCY.
THE OTHER THING THAT CAL WORN-
DOES IS THEY HAVE A WATER
SECTOR SAFETY POSITION INSIDE
AN EMERGENCY OPERATIONS CENTER
AND THESE ARE GENERALLY FOR. A
IT CAN ADD THE CITY OPERATIONS
CENTER OR THE STATE OPERATION
CENTERS AND THAT PARTICULAR
POSITION IS A WATER. SYSTEM NOT
AGE A PERSON WITH A DIFFERENT
KNOWLEDGE FOR THAT TYPE OF
WORK. AND THEY HAVE A COUPLE OF
TOOLS AVAILABLE AND I'D LIKE TO
GO THROUGH THOSE. AND THOSE
WERE YOU REFERRED TO MAP. SO
THE FOR TOOL THAT THEY HAVE TO
THE BENEFIT IS. ONE THAT STATE
MAP EQUAL CHANCE AND THIS IS
ACTUALLY A MAP FROM THE OF NAPA
CINEMA FIRES. AND IT'S A
COMBINATION OF THE MAP AND ONE
THOUGH THE- IF YOU HAVE AN IT
THE GREAT PART IS. FIRE. IN THE-
WHAT NURSES MAP IN THE LINES
THAT RUN ACROSS OUR CAL WERE
SEVEN MAY PUT IN WERE THERE LAW
ARE SO IF YOU'RE Y. SECTOR EVEN
DEEPER TRYING TO ANALYZE FOR
THE ASSISTANCE MIGHT BE NEEDED
IN A CATASTROPHIC EMERGENCY YOU
CAN LOOK IN IN THIS PARTICULAR
CASE A THE CENTER OF THE BLUE I
HAVE TO ME. SINCE YOU CAN BUY
THE MAP THAT FIRE ALREADY
DEVASTATED PART OF THE AREA AND
THEN THE WATER SYSTEMS NEAR
THAT AREA SO THAT MIGHT BE THE
BEST NEED AS FAR AS THAT GOES.
THERE IS ALSO IF YOU REFER TO
THE NEXT MAP WHICH IS THE
CAMPFIRE MAP. AND THIS WAS FROM
THE CAMPFIRE AND AGAIN
UTILIZING THE SAME. THREE MAPS
LAYERED ON TOP OF ONE ANOTHER
THIS ONE'S A LITTLE BIT
DIFFERENT THIS IS ACTUALLY WAS
IT A MINUTE IN TESTED AND
THEY'RE WORKING ON TRYING TO
PERFECT IT. IN IT'S THE GREEN
IS HE A WATER SYSTEM MAP FROM
DTW THE BLACK IS THE OUTLINE OF
THE CALIFORNIA MAP. AND THIS
ONE USES A MODUS SATELLITE
WHICH DETECTS HEAT SO IF YOU'RE
LOOKING AT THIS PARTICULAR MAP
THE CENTER PORTION IS
UNFORTUNATELY PARADISE. ALL
BURNED OUT BUT TO THE LEFT IS
CHICO AND SO YOU CAN TELL THAT
MAYBE AND NEXT CONCERN ON THIS
MIGHT BE THE CHICO SO. THOSE
ARE BOTH A TOOLS THAT ARE
AVAILABLE WITH THAT WATER SAFE.
SAFETY SECTOR POSITION. IN
CONCLUSION I HOPE THAT- WATER
AGENCIES WILL BE ENCOURAGED TO
JOIN CAL WORN AND I'LL BE
WILLING TO TAKE ANY QUESTIONS
AFTER THE COMMITTEE Q. GOOD
MORNING CHAIR MEMBERS FIRST I
WANT TO THANK THE COMMITTEE AND
THE STAFF FOR. THE INVITATION
TO PARTICIPATE IN THIS HEARING
WE REALLY APPRECIATE THE
SPECIAL ATTENTION THAT YOU'RE
TAKING- TO LOOK AT THE IMPACTS
OF PUBLIC SAFETY POWER SHUT OFF
SPECIFICALLY ON WATER AND
WASTEWATER. MY NAME IS JULIA
HALL I'M A SENIOR LEGISLATIVE
ADVOCATE WITH THE ASSOCIATION
OF CALIFORNIA WATER AGENCIES
AKA REPRESENTS OVER FOUR
HUNDRED FIFTY PUBLIC WATER
AGENCIES AROUND THE STATE
COLLECTIVELY. FOR NINE. UP
THESE AGENTS SUPPLY EATING
WATER REQUIRE. PANEL AMONG EACH
STORY IS UNIQUE AND SPECIFIC TO
THAT AGENCY THERE'S A NUMBER OF
COMMON CHALLENGES THAT EACH
AGENCY FACED- THE CENTRAL
CHALLENGES FOR THREE K. BRACE
FLEXIBILITY FUNDING AND
COMMUNICATION. THE FIRST BIG
CHALLENGE RELATES TO
FLEXIBILITY IN PROVIDING BACKUP
ELECTRIC POWER DURING THESE P.
S. P. S. EVENTS ATTHE
CONVEYANCE DELIVERY AND
TREATMENT OF WATER ALL REQUIRE
ELECTRICITY ABOUT THE VAST
MAJORITY OF CASES SO AN
ELECTRIC GRATE IS DE ENERGIZED.
WATER AGENCIES HAVE TO PROVIDE
THEIR OWN POWER AND CONTINUE TO
DELIVERY IT AND HE SAID EXCUSE
ME TO CONTINUE TO DELIVER AND
TREAT WATER FOR THE PUBLIC- IN
A WORST CASE SCENARIO WITHOUT
ELECTRICITY THERE'S THE
POTENTIAL FOR BOYLE ORDERS TO
BE TO THE POP. OUR DELIVERY TO
PLEASE STOP OR EVEN FOR ROSS
PUBLIC WAYS. AND THE CAL AIR IS
FOR LOCAL IT QUALITY MANAGEMENT
DOES ARE CHARGED WITH QUALITY
GOAL. THERE ARE VERY RIGHT HAVE
SOME. ON AIR BUT WATER AGENCY
RELY UPON TO FOR BACK POWER
THEIR SUBJECT TO THOSE RULES
AND STANDARDS. WHAT WATER
AGENCIES APPRECIATE THE
IMPORTANT ROLE OF THESE
REGULATORS. AND THE FLEXIBILITY
TO USE ME IN THESE CHAPTERS FOR
EMERGENCY EVENTS AS ESSENTIAL.
NUMBER RUBIO HAS GRACIOUSLY
AGREED TO AUTHOR A BILL ON
BEHALF OF AQUA THEY'LL ADDRESS
THE NEED FOR FLEXIBILITY DURING
P. S. P. S. EVENTS. I WANT TO
THANK HER AND HER STAFF AS WELL
AS THE STAFF OF THIS COMMITTEE
FOR THEIR IN TO WORK ON THE
ISSUE. AT A HIGH LEVEL. REPORT
CONTAINS A GREAT FLEXIBILITY.
THE COAST PROVIDERS NOT JUST
WATER AND WASTEWATER IN ORDER
TO ACCOMPLISH THREE MAIN GOALS.
FIRST TO CONFIRM THAT BACKUP
GENERATION DURING PS PS OF THAT
IS CONSIDERED EMERGENCY USE OF
GENERATORS. SEC TO ENSURE THE
GENERAL USE FOR YES PS EVENTS
IS NOT WITH ANY TIME PAINS. AND
THAT NATIONAL TESTING IN
MAKING. IF IT IS GENERAL SINCE
THEY'RE BEING PUT UNDER GERMAN
AND THAT THEY WERE REALLY. FOR
AN WE'RE INTEREST SOLUTION. I
BELIEVE. I ALSO FOUGHT OUT IF
UNDERSTANDING THAT BY AIR THE
END ARE PORTENT FOR HELP AND
SAFETY. SECOND MAIN TOWN REALLY
STUFF. BUT FOR EVERY MISSILE
ABOUT. AND FOR REIMBURSEMENT
FOR A HIGH AND BECAUSE INCURRED
A RESULT P. S. P. A WELL
FUNDING IS ALL CHALLENGING FOR
PUBLIC A TO USE ISSUE IS REALLY
URGE AND PROCUREMENT OF.
GENERATION CAN BE PRETTY
LENGTHY. WE APPRECIATE THE
FUNDING IN THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET IN THE FORM OF GRANTS
ADMINISTERED BY THE CALIFORNIA
OFFICE OF EMERGENCY SERVICES I
THINK COUPLE PEOPLE TOUCHED ON
THIS LAST YEAR THE BUDGET MADE
SEVENTY FIVE MILLION DOLLARS
AVAILABLE TO CITIES AND
COUNTIES PREPARE FOR PS PS- BUT
UNFORTUNATELY SPECIAL DISTRICTS
IN THERE FOR MANY WATER
AGENCIES WERE INELIGIBLE TO.
BUY FOR THIS FUNDING. THE
PROPOSED. COULD FIT AND ALL.
AND IS INTENDED. TO WATER
AGENTS AND OTHER SPECIAL
DISTRICTS. WE APPRECIATE THE
RECOGNITION OF WATER AGENCIES
NEEDS IN THIS YEAR'S PROPOSED
FUNDING. BUT WE ARE CONCERNED
THAT THE SMALLER PART OF
FUNDING MAY NOT BE ADEQUATE TO
MEET THE FULL NEED. THERE ARE
OTHER SOURCES OF FUNDING SPREAD
ACROSS A NUMBER OF STATE AND
FEDERAL AGENCIES. INCLUDING THE
CLEAN AND SAFE DRINKING WATER
REVOLVING FUNDS ADMINISTERED BY
THE STATE WATER RESOURCES
CONTROL BOARD AND THERE IS SOME
THEME OF FUNDING. REQUIREMENTS
FROM PATCHING FUNDS AND SOME OF
THESE. HOWEVER CAN BE
PROHIBITIVE FOR SOME OF OUR
SMALL AGENCY. IN ORDER TO AVOID
A- INVESTMENTS IN BACKUP
GENERATORS WE WOULD ASK THE
LEGISLATURE FOR OVERSIGHT OVER
HOW THE ELECTRIC ELECTRIC
UTILITIES INVEST IN HARDENING
THEIR INFRASTRUCTURE. AND HOW
THEY PRIORITY CRITICAL
FACILITIES THAT PROVIDE MENTAL
HEALTH AND SAFETY THIS AS- IN
ADDITION TO THE NEED FOR
INVESTMENTS WATER AND
WASTEWATER AGENCIES ALSO
ENCOURAGE YOU JUMP BUDGET COSTS
IN THE PREPARATION EXECUTION
AND AFTERMATH OF THESE PEACE PS
EVENTS. THE COSTS ARE MEMBERS
ENCOURAGED. THE SMALLER LARGER
AGENCIES RANGING FROM THOUSANDS
TO TENS OF THOUSANDS AND MAYBE
EVEN MORE PER DAY- BASED ON
WHAT THEY HAD TO DO TO GET
PREPARED. ADDRESSING THESE I'M
BUDGET BECAUSE IF YOU'RE-
THIRTY OF THE LEGISLATURE AND
WE WOULD ASK ANY LET. THAT
SEEKS REIMBURSEMENT FOR COSTS
INCURRED CONSIDER SPECIAL
DISTRICTS. THE FINAL SIGNIFICAN
CHALLENGER LEADS TO
COMMUNICATION COMMUNICATION
WITH THE ELECTRIC UTILITIES BUT
ALSO COMMUNICATION WITH OTHER
CRITICAL SERVICE PROVIDERS. FOR
MEMBERS IN SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
EDISON AND PACIFIC GAS AND
ELECTRIC TERRITORIES THE LEVEL
FREQUENCY AN ACCURACY OF
COMMUNICATION WARRANT SOME
IMPROVEMENT. YOU PUBLIC
UTILITIES COMMISSION RECOGNIZES
THAT WOULD BURN WASTE WTER
AGENCIES ARE CRITICAL STATE
FACILITIES AND THEY'RE EXPECTED
TO BE GIVEN ADVANCE NOTICE AND
IN A IN ADVANCE OF PS PS. A
TIME SOME OF OUR MEMBERS HAD
FACILITIES LOSE POWER THAT
WE'RE NOT SUPPOSED TO LOSE
POWER AND MANY OF OUR MEMBERS
ARE NOTED THERE LOOK TRICITY
MAY GO OUT BUT THEY WERE NEVER
GETTING CONFIRMATION OUR TIME.
AT THIS SPECIFIC. PATIENT
ASSIST. FOR WATER. PREPARE FOR
AND MAINTAIN RELIABILITY DURING
P. S. P. S. EVENTS. MANY THE
CHALLENGES I'VE OUTLINED OR NOT
YOU NEED TO WATER AGENCIES AND
THERE ARE PROBABLY A LOT OF
LEGISLATIVE PROPOSALS THIS YEAR
TO LOOK AT THE IMPROVEMENTS
THAT ARE NEEDED ON THE ELECTRIC
UTILITY SIDE AND WHERE
APPROPRIATE WILL WAIT. ON THAT.
AND ONE OTHER PIECE THAT WAS.
BY THE LAST PANEL IS THE STRESS
ON THE TELECOMS AND NETWORK AND
I THINK THAT- THAT HASN'T
REALLY BEEN HIGHLIGHTED AS WELL
AND I KNOW THAT THEY'RE
STRUGGLING WITH SOME OF THESE
SAME ISSUES BEING CRITICAL
FACILITIES ON WHEN BUT OF OUR
WATER AGENCIES RAN INTO ISSUES
WHERE THEY COULDN'T COMMUNICATE
BECAUSE THEY'RE RLIANT UPON
NETWORKS THAT WEREN'T
AVAILABLE. I'M SUCH ONE OTHER
PIECE ON COMMUNICATION WE'RE
ALSO BEING PROACTIVE HOWEVER
OUTSIDE OF THE LEGISLATORS FEAR
NOT ALL OF THESE TO BE SOLVED
BY THE POLICYMAKERS- IF WE CAN
HELP YOU GUYS OUT WE'RE TRYING
TO DO THAT WE'RE TRYING TO OUR
ROADS WITH THEY'LL BE DELIRIOUS
SO FOR EXAMPLE LAST WEEK A
SMALL CONTINGENT OF OUR BUT-
YEAH. IN TOWARD THE EMERGENCE
OPERATION ARE MANTA I SAN DIEGO.
ELECTRIC TO LEARN FROM WHAT
THEY'VE BEEN DOING OVER THE
LAST SEVERAL YEARS IN
ATTENDANCE WERE ALSO
REPRESENTATIVES FROM PGA ANY
AND AS C. E. WHO WERE THERE TO
LEARN FROM WHAT THEY'VE BEEN
WORKING ON DOWN IN SAN DIEGO.
AND ALSO IT RIGHT IT'S OF THEIR
OWN TO OUR MEMBERSHIP. I WILL
CONTINUE TO CORDON. UTILITY
PARTNERS TO PROVIDE FACE TO
FACE OPPORTUNITIES WITH THE
WATER COMMUNITY. THESE PEACE PS
OF MY EVENTS ALSO HIGHLIGHTED
DIFFERENT KIND OF COMMUNICATION
CHALLENGE AT LEAST FOR SOME OF
OUR MEMBERS- WHICH IS A LACK OF
INTEGRATION OF THE LOCAL
GOVERNMENT EMERGENCY RESPONSE
LEVEL- WELL THIS ISN'T SOLELY A
P. S. P. S. ISSUE PS PS IS
HIGHLIGHTED. A THAT THERE'S A
NEED FOR BETTER COORDINATION
AND INTEGRATION AT THAT LEVEL.
BECAUSE IT WE ARE SPECIAL
DISTRICTS. COUNTIES OF THE
OBSERVE EMERGENCY RESPONSE
THROUGHOUT THE STATE. AND SPOCK
STATEWIDE ASSOCIATIONS DEFINE.
CAN BETTER PARTNER WORK
TOGETHER. ALL THESE CHALLENGES
NEED. SO SOME OF THESE. CAN BE
A CO. THE PARTNERSHIP. WHILE
OTHERS MANY LEGISLATIVE ACTION.
I APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY
FOR PUBLIC WATER AGENCIES TO
SHARE THEIR STORIES AND FOR ALL
QUITE A SURE POTENTIAL
SOLUTIONS THESE ONGOING
CHALLENGES. AND THEN WITH THAT
I'D BE HAPPY WITH ANY QUESTIONS
THANK YOU OPEN OPEN UP TO SOME
QUESTIONS. MARIE QUESTIONS.
OKAY HE TOUCHED ON THE FUNDING
AND SOME OF THE CENTER
CHALLENGES THAT EXIST- WITH THE
STATE AGENCIES HOW CAN YOU BE
MORE SPECIFIC IF POSSIBLE ON
SOME OF THOSE CHALLENGES IN
TERMS OF SOME OF THE FUNDING
BACKS A LEXUS IN THE SIDE FROM
THE AMOUNT THAT'S AVAILABLE YES
I THINK SO- SO WE WERE AT
ACCESS TO THE FUNDING THAT WAS
IN THE BUDGET LAST YEAR'S
OBVIOUSLY THAT'S A CHALLENGE I
THINK. THE RECORD AND THIS YEAR.
CONVERSATIONS AS A PRO. AND
OTHER FUNDING THE ALREADY SORT
OF OUT THERE AVAILABLE THE WHAT
REVOLVING FUNDS THAT I MENTION
I THINK. WITH THEIR VENDORS
WITH THOUGH WHY RESOURCES BOARD
THIS FUND WOULD BE AVAILABLE
FOR THAT I THINK THAT THAT
FUNDING IS ALSO INTENDED FOR A
MYRIAD OF OTHER THINGS. SO
YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT A LOT OF
COMPETING INTERESTS FOR US YOU
KNOW AS A CERTAIN PART OF
MONEY. AND THAT FLOWS THROUGH
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT TO THE
STATE TO ADMINISTER SO I THINK.
THERE ARE FUNDING STREAMS. BULL
BUT- THERE'S THOSE ARE ALREADY
CUT MARCH FOR OTHER ACTIVITIES
TWELVE. THERE'S JUST LOOK COME
TO MODIFY WHICH THE START OF
PUBLIC AGENCIES AND GENERAL.
OKAY REGARDING REGIONAL LOOK
WORK AT COORDINATION WHAT'S
THAT LOOK FROM REGION TO REGION
SEVERAL BASS THEY TRY TO BE THE
THAT CALIFORNIA'S DIVIDED WITH
THE FIVE REGIONS AND THROUGHOUT
THE STATE- THEY TRY TO FIRST
LOOK. AT THE PART OF THE STATE
MEDIA YOU KIND OF COLLECTIVELY
LOOK AT WHAT YOU HAVE AVAILABLE
WE HAVE THAT TYPE THE METHODS
THROUGH MY SO THERE'S SOME OF
THAT AGENCIES ASSISTANCE UP
THAT THEY CAN UTILIZE IS BASED
THAT I YEAH YEAH SHOP TO THE-
FOR. THE NEXT NEED THEM THE
OTHER OPTIONS AS WELL I.
SOMETHING THAT'S COME UP QUITE
A IS THE ISSUE JENNA. YES AND
DOM WATER AGENTS LOOKING AT
OTHER. ALTERNATIVES TO
GENERATORS IN OF SO WHERE THEY
LOOK LIKE AND- MAYBE IDEA OF
COST COMPARISONS- SO WE THE
CITY OF SACRAMENTO IS BAD HAS
MOST OF THEIR PART POWER BASED
ON SPOTTED. A WE ARE USUALLY A
ONE YEAR OLD USUALLY THE ONE
THAT THEY REACH OUT TO FORTY
READY YET AS FAR AS A DIFFERENT
SORT FOR ALTERNATIVES. I CAN
GET NOW I'M NOT SURE. IT WHAT
ARE YOU SEE YES SO FROM LAST
THE RIGHT. ABOUT IT PROBLEM AND
SO. FOR AN IMMEDIATE SOLUTION
CAN BE PRETTY AND PUT IN PLACE
I THINK SOME OF THEM TOUCH ON
THE FACT THAT SOME OF THE
TECHNOLOGY STILL ISN'T QUITE
THERE- AND I THINK. YOU'RE
DOING IF YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT
SOME ESPECIALLY SOME OF THESE
ARE AGENCIES AND OVER A HUNDRED
YLIDES W. FOR DIFFERENT
MICROGRAMS THAT YOU NEED TO
INVEST IN SO IF YOU THINK ABOUT
THE KIND OF IT THAT WOULD NEED
TO GO INTO. THE THING THAT WE
NEED TO GO. SB BACK. LONG
HAITIAN TO GET THAT IN
POTENTIAL I'M A LOT OF ROOM
HAVE ANGRY AS INVEST IN A LOT
OF TECH I WILL SAY THAT I. THE
MINDSET THAT THEY NEEDTO BE
THEIR OWN ALL BURKE PROVIDER
WAS NOT REALLY PART OF THAT
DISCUSSION AT THE TIME IT WAS
MORE ABOUT- SELLING BACK TO THE
GRANTED OVER CUTTING COSTS AT
PEAK TIMES. AND SO ALMOST ALL
OF THE MEMBERS AWARE OF THE
HAVE INVESTED IN THESE KINDS OF
YOU KNOW EITHER STROLLER OR
BATTERY OR- COMBINATION. IT'S
NOT SET UP TO BE BEHIND THE EAR
OR ISLAND IT. SO DURING THESE
POWER OUTAGES THEY ACTUALLY
DON'T HAVE ACCESS THAT
ELECTRICITY AND NOT BACK UP. SO
IS THE POTENTIAL TO CONVERT
SOME OF THAT AND MAYBE AT
CERTAIN VESSEL. PROBE BUT I
THINK THAT FOR THE- PART- THAT
THAT GENERATED REALLY THE BEST
SOLUTION. BASED SO DO YOU HAVE
ANY IDEA WHAT KIND OF A
INVESTMENT YOU WOULD NEED AS
FAR I MEAN I KNOW FOR A MILLION
DOLLARS. LIKE A LOT OF. IN
REALITY IT'S NOT DO YOU HAVE
ANY IDEA WHAT. THE NEED IS- I
THINK WE NEED TO DO SOME MORE
WORK WITH OUR MEMBERSHIP TO GET
A BETTER SENSE OF EXACTLY WHAT
THEY NEED IS I THINK THE OTHER
THING ABOUT AT LEAST AS
POSSIBLE OUT OF MONEY. THAT
CITIES AND COUNTIES AND OTHERS
BUT- ALSO PROBABLY HAVE THAT.
NEEDS BUT THAT'S SOMETHING THAT
WORKING ON. AND JUST TO GIVE
YOU A SENSE MOST OF THESE
ESPECIALLY LARGER GENERATORS
ARE CUSTOM BUILT. AT THEIR
ANYWHERE FROM FIVE HUNDRED
THOUSAND TO OVER IN THE-
GREATER- AND THEY TAKE.
PROBABLY SIX MONTHS TO A YEAR
TO ACTUALLY HAVE DESIGNED AND
BUILT OUT. SO I THINK WE
PROBABLY DO NEED SOME BETTER
NUMBERS ON EXACTLY WHAT THE
NEED IS. BUT IN FIFTY IN. A LOT
LESS. BAR THAT ONE TAKE THAT I
MIGHT. SO HAVE WHAT WHAT RETAIN
OUT A JUDGE TO FOR A WHOLE SITE
FOR IT REALLY DEPEND IT'S ALL
VERY FACILITIES SEC- SO THERE
THERE'S DIFFERENT WATTAGE THAT
YOU MIGHT NEED DIFFERENT I'M
THE POWER THEY'RE GOING BUT
INTO THAT SYSTEM TO. RUN
CAPACITY AND SO IT DEPENDS
INDIVIDUAL THE TRYING ON WITH.
FOR A TREATMENT PLANT WENT
DOWN- THAN THEY NEEDED THE
BACKUP POWER THEY WERE ON THE
SIZE OF ABOUT THREE FEET THE
TWO FORMER FIFTY KILOWATT SO
THAT'S KIND OF AN IDEA. THANK
YOU. I DON'T HAVE ANY FURTHER
QUESTIONS IN THE QUEUE AGAIN
FOR A SPENDING THIS MORNING
WITH US AS WELL AS ALL OF THE
OTHER PRESENTERS AND TURN EAGER
TO HEAR FROM. THOSE IN THE
AUDIENCE WHO WILL BE SPEAK.
DURING PUBLIC COMMENTS AND GO
AGAIN THANK YOU ALL OF THE
ANALYST. FOR THEIR- QUESTIONS
COMMENTS OR CONCERNS ARE ON THE
RECORD- TO PLEASE COME FORWARD
STATE YOUR NAME- ORGANIZATION A
AFFILIATION. AND JOB YOU KNOW.
PLEASE KEEP YOUR COMMENTS.
BRIEF. A GOOD MORNING MISTER
CHAIR AND MEMBERS AT MY NAME IS
VINCE WERE AT MUCH OF WITH THE
WHITE MAN GROUP HERE ON BEHALF
OF CALIFORNIA WHAT IS ONE OF
THE STATE'S. WATER REACHED.
RIGHT BY THE PUBLIC. PLEASE
SHARE AN ECHO THE CONCERNS OF
WITNESSES THAT WE HEARD FROM
TODAY. WHAT'S AT STAKE HERE IS
NOT LESS THAN OUR ABILITY TO
PROVIDE. CUSTOMERS WITH SAFE
AND RELIABLE. WATER UTILITY
SERVICE. LIKE CALAVERAS COUNTY
WE'D LIKE TO FLAG THE
POSSIBILITY OF WATER SUPPLIERS
WHETHER THEY BE PUBLIC OR
PRIVATE. OF BEING HELD LIABLE
FOR THE DAMAGES CAUSED BY FIRES
THAT ARE IGNITED DESPITE PS PS
THAT EVENTS. THESE PENSION
LIABILITIES THREATEN THE
FINANCIAL VIABILITY OF EACH OF
THE STATE'S PUBLIC WATER
SYSTEMS PUBLIC OR PRIVATE. AND
WITH IT THE LADY OF. UP PROVIDE
SAFETY AND LEE AT THE ENSURE
THE SAFETY AND RELIABILITY OF
OUR DRINKING WATER IN
COMMUNITIES ACROSS CALIFORNIA.
GIVEN THE PS PS EVENTS ARE.
THIS LIABILITY ISSUE NEEDS TO
BE ADDRESSED IN THE VERY NEAR
TERM IN ORDER TO ENSURE THAT
ALL WATER SYSTEMS ARE ABLE TO
NEED TO MEET THE RESPONSIBILITY
OF PROVIDING SAFE DRINK THANK
YOU. HI MY NAME IS A
CARRAGEENAN GENERAL MANAGER
SALON OR GAYS AND DISTRICT AND
SOLANO COUNTY. OUR AGENCY OP AN
AXE SYSTEM BUT IT ALSO OPERATES
WE HAVE. EIGHT DIFFERENT
DRINKING WATER SYSTEMS AND WE
HAVE VARYING A CUSTOMER SIZES
FOR THOSE DIFFERENT SYSTEMS
DEPEND ON WHERE YOU ARE. OF
THEM IS LARGELY ABOUT THOUSAND
CONNECTION TO NOT SYSTEM BUT
MOST OF THEM ARE SMALL RANGING
FROM TWENTY FIVE CONNECTIONS UP
TO A HUNDRED AND SEVENTY
CONNECTIONS. AND THEY'RE
SEPARATED GEOGRAPHICALLY EACH
OTHER BY MILES IN THEIR IN
RURAL COUNTY AREAS INSIDE
COUNTY SO NORTH OF UP NORTH OF
A FAIRFIELD IN KIND OF THE
TRANSITIONAL AREA. BERMAN TO A
KIND OF WILD LANDS. OR DRINKING
WATERS OF THE EIGHT OF THEM.
FLYING YES. INTO AN WITHOUT ARE
IN TEEN AND. I'M NOT SOME. STAY
GIVE YOU A FLAVOR OF SOME OF
THESE SMALL SYSTEMS WHEN HAVE A
SUB PROVIDING WHY AT A
REASONABLE COST TO CUSTOMERS
EARLY ENOUGH GAME IN A FEW OF A
LAW CUSTOMERS YOU WITHIN A
FAIRLY. COST TO YOUR CUSTOMERS
THEY DON'T REALLY ACT. YOU HAVE
RELEASED SYSTEMS LIKE A 25%
SYSTEM FOR EXAMPLE IT'S REALLY
HARD TO SPREAD OUT COST AND SO
WHEN YOU HAVE TO GO OUT AND
BUY. TWO SEVEN THOUSAND DOLLARS
THE RAIDER AND PUT ANOTHER
THOUSAND DOLLARS INTO TO GET
THEM CONNECTED YOU SPENT TWO
HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS. ON A
SYSTEM. THERE IN THE IN THE
PARTICULAR. GIVING AUDIT ON THE
SYSTEM TWENTY PEOPLE AND THEIR
HOWEVER MONTHLY BILLS ALL THE
FIVE HUNDRED DOLLARS A MONTH.
MENDOZA IMPACT TO THE THOSE
CUSSED SOME OF OUR OTHERS THIRD
THERE THE ALL VERY SIMILAR THAT
PROBABLY THE BUT WE HAVE
ANOTHER SYSTEM THAT'S A HUNDRED
SEVENTY CUSTOMERS. THE NEED FOR
THEM IS ALSO- BROTHER
STAGGERING IN THERE'S A
QUESTION EARLIER TODAY ABOUT
WELL WHAT'S THE TO. INCREASE
IMPACT. A TWO IF YOU WERE TO
OUT AND PURCHASE AND THEN
OPERATE- THE GENERATORS FOR THE
SYSTEMS WELL FOR THE SYSTEM SO
WE'RE LOOKING AT. FOR EACH ONE
IT WOULD BE ANYWHERE FROM A
5210% INCREASE. THAT WOULD BE
AN AND CREATES. ABOVE AND
BEYOND WHICH ARE NEEDED FOR
SPRINT REINFORCEMENT AND TO. IF
FOR THE OF. THE BODIES KIND OF
FAITH. AGING INFRASTRUCTURE. IN
THIS KIND OF. ITS IT UP OF IT
IS IT IS A QUITE A TALENTED. WE
WOULD UP SO WHAT MY AGENCY
WOULD ALL LIKE TO REQUEST THAT
THE THIS IS A PART IN IT. IN
THE BUD. DRY BUT MINOR BIT OF
MILLION. THING YES THE CARD.
WASTE INTO SPECIAL DISTRICTS TO
HELP COPE WITH THE THESE
ENORMOUS BECAUSE OF VERY MUCH
THANK YOU. MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
BRENDAN TO A GUN BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA AIR POLLUTION
CONTROL OFFICERS ASSOCIATION
THAT'S EXECUTIVE OFFICERS FROM
ALL FIVE LOCAL AIR DISTRICTS
I'M JUST ON THIS ISSUE OF BACK
UP A DIESEL BACKUP GENERATORS.
THEY WERE VERY SENSITIVE I
ISSUE IN THE ABILITY. I
PROVIDED THE NEEDS GENERATION
THAT THAT IS THEIR DURING P. S.
P. S. EVENTS AND ALSO EMERGENCY
EVENTS WERE AWARE OF ANY AIR
DISTRICT IT'S FIND ANYBODY
DURING ONE OF THESE EVENTS- AND
OR HIS BODY UNDER ONE OF THESE
EVENTS. SO YOU KNOW WE
CERTAINLY ARE OUT I THINK
THERE'S A NEED FOR PERHAPS
COMMUNICATION WITH SOME OF THE
LOCAL WATER DISTRICTS WITH
THEIR AIR DISTRICTS AND I LOOK
FORWARD TO HAVING FOR. THE
DISCUSSIONS I. MISTER CHAIRMAN
COMMITTEE- MY NAME'S ALAN
ABSENT WITH THE BAY AREA AIR
QUALITY MANAGEMENT DISTRICT IN
WHERE THE AIR QUALITY REGULATOR
FOR THE EAST BAY MUD SO I
APPRECIATE. APPRECIATE HIS
REMARKS ABOUT- THE WORK THAT
THEY DON'T EAST BAY MUD IN THAT
THEY DO BALLOTS THE NEEDS OF
THE MINUTE MUNICIPAL UTILITY
DISTRICT WITH. BODY NEEDS WHEN
I WHEN I LOOK AT ARMAMENTS YOUR
CALL DISTRICT HAS ON ESSENTIAL
PUBLIC FACILITIES AND AN
EMERGENCY POWER USAGE WE HAVE
WE HAVE UNLIMITED HOURS OF
OPERATION. URGENCY FOR BACK THE
GENERATOR WE HAVE A PRETTY WE
HAVE UP. UP TO READ OUT. BY
ABILITY TEST WHICH MAINTENANCE
IN. MAINTENANCE TESTING. TO THE
OF MEN IF UP FOR THE- FIND THAT
THE- IN THOSE OURS TO EAT
PROPERLY CARED FOR EMERGING
THERE IS A THERE A IT CAN
PROCESS WITH THE AIR DISTRICT
TO LOOK AT WHAT THEIR PERMIT
REQUIREMENTS ARE IN TO SEE IF
SAID ADDITIONAL HOURS OPERATION
WOULD BE. TO GET THROUGH THAT
CYCLE SO UP PART TWO. BRIDGE
THE ARE UTILITIES TO HAVE WITH
THEIR LOCAL DISK AND I WOULD
COST OF MEMBERS THE COMMITTEE
ABOUT- BLANKET EXEMPTION OF
LOCAL STATE OR FEDERAL AIR
QUALITY. THE SOLUTION TO THIS
PROBLEM. YOU GOOD MORNING CHAIR
GARCIA MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
MY NAME IS MICHAEL HADLEY O
THE GOVERNMENT RELATIONS
OFFICER FOR WESTERN MUNICIPAL
WATER DISTRICT WHERE WATER
DISTRICT DOWN IN WESTERN
RIVERSIDE COUNTY THAT COVER
ABOUT FIVE HUNDRED TWENTY FIVE
SQUARE MILES AND SERVE WATER ON
A WHOLESALE AND RETAIL IS TO A
LITTLE UNDER MILLION PEOPLE.
ARKANSAS WITH. ALL ONE IN THE
CASE WE HAVEIN GOOD RELATION
WITH OUR PUBLIC ARE EXCUSE ME
OUR ELECTORAL PROVIDER FOR THE
AREA AND- IN THE EVENT THAT WE
A PROPER NOTIFICATION WE CAN
USE OUR LOW SOURCES THAT UNDER
BASED IN AND MOVE THEM HILL AND
THEN SERVE CUSTOMERS WHICH YOUR
YOU. BRING HIM. TIME ANY CASE
INDICATE WHERE- PSP AS OF THAT
GOES OVER A FEW DAYS OR MAYBE
THERE'S AN UNFORESEEN
CIRCUMSTANCE WHERE PSCS OFFENSE
NEEDS TO OCCUR- WE NEED TO BE
ABLE TO USE OUR BACKUP
GENERATORS ONLINE AND USE THEM
WITHOUT ANY. LIES ATION. ONLY
ALL HE COULD REALLY USE SOME
SUPPORT IN FUNDING FOR
UPGRADING SOMEWHERE FACILITIES-
THAT SUPPORT OF BEEN TALKING
ABOUT EARLIER IN A FUNDING
CENSUS CRITICAL WERE HAVING TO
INVEST MILLIONS OF DOLLARS OF.
OUR FACILITIES GREAT THOSE ARE
PRETTY INTEREST. YOU HAVE
GENERAL. IN CAN HAVE AND IT
COSTS I ANYWHERE UP TO FOR THE
DOLLARS. A FOR US TO READ
GENERATORS THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME THANK HAVING THIS HEARING.
THANK YOU. HI ALYSSA SO HIGH
WITH THE CALIFORNIA SPECIAL
DISTRICTS ASSOCIATION AND WE
REPRESENT OVER A THOUSAND OF
THE INDEPENDENT SPECIAL
DISTRICTS IN CALIFORNIA AND
PROVIDE CRITICAL SERVICES
INCLUDING WATER AND WASTEWATER
DISTRICT. DISTRICT TYPE YOU
ALSO WERE ENGAGED IN THE
DELIVERY OF WATER AND WOULD
LIKE TO THANK THE COMMITTEE FOR
RECOGNIZING THE IMPORTANCE THIS
ISSUE IN TODAY'S HEARING. ALSO
WANTED NO RPG IN FURTHERING THE
MISTER LAMB L. AT AND HELLO YES
IN THE AFTERMATH OF LAST YEAR
pTAKEAWAYS AS OUR MEMBER WAS
THAT. ENHANCE. COMMUNICATION
AND COORDINATE. BOTH AT THE
AGENCY. AND I'M OF UNDER.
ANYTHING PERHAPS OF THE NATURE
OF JUST AND I'M JUST HOW MANY
CRITICAL FACILITIES AND
INFRASTRUCTURE WE OPERATE IN
CALIFORNIA AND SO WE'VE BEEN
ENGAGED WITH CALLOW YES TO
TRYING AND BETTER. COORDINATE
AND COMMUNITY ACTION AND LOOK
FORWARD TO. CONTINUING AN
AFRICAN ALSO LOOK FOR IN
WORKING WITH THE LEGISLATURE TO
DEAL EDUCATE AND TO MAYBE AND
FILLED GAPS IN I ALSO WOULD
LIKE. BILL AT ECHO THE REMARKS
FROM ANY OTHER MARKS MADE BY
THE GENTLEMAN ANALYSTS WHO WERE
RECORD WATER DISTRICTS IT THEIR
ALL BACHELOR IT IS AS WELL AS
WELL AS- OUR- THE- CREATED
SIGNIFICAN COST AND AN
OPERATIONAL CHALLENGES- AND
THEY ARE GOING TO REQUIRE
INNOVATIVE AND CREATIVE
SOLUTIONS AND WE LOOK FORWARD
TO WORKING WITH YOU AS THE
MOVES FORWARD TO BEING OF THE
SOLUTIONS THANK YOU. THE THEN
TYPE WITH CAL MUNICIPAL
UTILITIES ASSOCIATION I WON'T
TAKE UP MUCH TIME BECAUSE I'M
THE LAST- SPEAKER FOR PUBLIC
COMMENT BUT REALLY WANTED
APPRECIATE THE COMMITTEE'S
ATTENTION TO THIS ISSUE AND
ECHO MOST OF THE COMMENTS OF
NOT ALL OF MY COLLEAGUES FROM
THE LOCAL EXPAND FROM THE
VISION OF CALIFORNIA WATER AND
SEES AS ON THE JOB AND FROM LOS
VIRGINIS I'M NOTED WE ARE AND
WE DO HAVE A PROPOSAL TO TRY
AND OF SHE BALLOT RESPECTING
THEIR- RULES IT ALSO. ANY
MADDEN TERRY TBILISI WE RISE
THAT NOT ALL AIR DISTRICTS
LIMITS BUT THERE ARE SOME THAT
DO ADDRESS OR HOPING TO FIND
THAT BALANCE AND APPRECIATE THE
TIME THANK YOU ALL RIGHT THANK
YOU SEE WHAT ELSE. WANT TO STAY
PUBLIC COMMENTS ON YOU ALL FOR
BEING HERE WHY OF. THANK MY
COLLEAGUES WHO WELL ATTENDED
THE HEARING AND- THIS- MEETING
WILL BE A JERK. THANK YOU.